welcome to the beginner's course on how
to build 12 data apps in python
with streamlit my name is
and i'll be your instructor for today
some of you might know me as
the data professor from my youtube
channel data professor
where i teach data science machine
learning and also provide a
bioinformatics project walkthrough aside
from being a youtuber i'm also an
associate professor
of bioinformatics where i teach and do
research
at the interface of machine learning and
computational
drug discovery in this course we will be
building
12 interactive data-driven web
applications
in python using the streamlit library
so streamlight will allow you to make
use of data
and also all of the python libraries
such as
numpy scipy maps.lib seaborn
right inside the python environment and
you'll also be
able to create an interactive web
application
that will be able to pre-process data
sets visualize the data
and also make prediction from machine
learning in the form of a web
application
so a basic working knowledge of python
is assumed
but don't worry i'll be holding your
hand and provide you with a step-by-step
walkthrough where i will be trying my
best to simplify the concept
and topics covered before proceeding
further
let's take a look at the 12 data web
applications
that we will be building today i've also
rearranged the topic
according to the topics covered and so
in apps number one and eight
we will be building a very simple stock
price application
app number eight we will be building a
simple bioinformatics dna count
application afterwards we will be
building four
eda applications using the basketball
data
football data s p 500 stock price and
also the
cryptocurrency price data we'll also be
developing
two classification models and embedding
that into the web application
for the iris data set and also the
penguins data set
we'll also be building two regression
models on the boston housing data
and also the bioinformatics solubility
data and finally
we'll also be showing you how you can
deploy your application
to the heroku platform and also to the
trimlet
sharing platform and so for more data
science machine learning
and bioinformatics projects please make
sure to
subscribe to my youtube channel the data
professor
and also follow me on medium where i
regularly
publish blog posts on data science and
also machine learning
so links to all of these are provided in
the description of this
video also grab yourself a cup of coffee
and without further ado let's get
started
have you ever wanted to build a
data-driven web application
for your data science projects but
perhaps you might be intimidated by the
difficulty of coding in django
or in flask if you answered one or all
of the above
then you want to watch this video to the
end because i'm going to show you how
you could build a
data-driven web application in just a
few lines of code and so without further
ado
let's get started so the name of the
python library that allows you to build
a
simple data-driven web application is
called
streamlit actually this python library
was brought to my attention by one of
the subscribers of this youtube channel
so please give a big hand to iqbal for
recommending this
excellent python library that will allow
you to develop a
simple data-driven web application for
your data science
project and so the first thing that you
want to do
is head over to the streamlet website by
typing in
streamlit.io and so i'm going to provide
you the link
in the description of this video so this
is the website of streamlit
and as you will see it says that it is
the fastest way to build a data
application
and so here you can see that you could
build a opencv
web application from within streamlit
and you could add a lot of
interactive elements as well
so in order to get started you want to
install streamlid and so you could do
that by typing in pip
install streamlit and after the
installation process
is finished you could type in streamlit
hello in order to check that it has
successfully been installed
and as you can see here a simple web
application could be built in just
a few lines of code and you will see in
this second example that you could also
add
widgets to the web application as well
and so this slider widget will allow you
to
select numbers just by sliding the
slider bar
and in this third example here you could
deploy
your web application easily using git
and there you have it a minimal
framework for building a
powerful web application while just
requiring you
just a few lines of code and so here are
some of the
gallery of web application built using
streamlit
so let's have a look at the gallery okay
so this
awesome web application using tensorflow
was built in streamlit and there are
other
awesome examples of streamlit
applications
that were built by the user community
and so here are just a selection of
these
so if you have built a web application
using streamlit you could also
share it via twitter and the streamlate
website will be
showcasing your web application in this
gallery page so you can see here that a
wide variety
of web applications have been built
using streamlit
okay so now that we have a brief
introduction about streamlit let's have
a look at how we can build one for
ourself
okay so the first thing that you want to
do is
fire up your terminal so if you're using
a microsoft windows you want to type in
the search bar cmd
and then you will see a terminal prompt
coming up and in this terminal prompt
you want to type in pip install
and then stream lit and then hit enter
and since i have already installed
streamlit so i'm going to proceed with
showing you how you can build the
application so i installed streamlit
inside the contact environment
and so i want to activate my environment
by typing in conda activate dp
alright so i've created a python file
called
myapp.py and the contents of the file is
shown here
so you can see that it is approximately
20 lines of code so if you deduct the
empty spaces then
it should be less than 20 lines of code
and so
aside from installing streamlit in this
example you also want to install
why finance so you could type in pip
install y finance okay and
after you have done so then you wanna
type the following lines of code in
but for your convenience i'm gonna share
you the link
to this file on the data professor
github so you want to check in the
description of this video
and download this file okay so the first
three lines of code are just simply
importing the y finance as y f
import streamlit sst import pandas as
pd and then this block of code we're
going to write the
header of the web application so as you
will see here that this is in markdown
language
and with the hashtag here it is
indicating that
this line is a heading type one so it's
going to be a big text
and then it's going to be an ordinary
text saying shown are the stock closing
price
and volume of google and then here in
this blocks of code i've taken
from the towards data science article so
you want to check that article out
and give this article a clap and so
i extracted some lines from this article
and so
this line of code will be the ticker
symbol
of google and so it is g-o-o-g-l
and then in this line of code we're
gonna take in the ticker symbol
of google and so we're gonna retrieve
historical data
of google stock price with a period set
at one day
and the starting date is may 31st 2010
with a ending date of may 31st 2020 and
then we're gonna save this into the
ticker data frame and then the contents
of this data frame will comprise of the
following columns
open high low close volume
dividends and stock splits okay so in
this web application we're gonna show
you
two line chart and we're gonna show the
closing price
and also the volume okay and so this is
a very simple
web application and you could customize
this to your own liking
so i'm gonna show you that we could also
edit the contents of the
file and the web application will be
serving the
updated version in real time alright
so let's type in cd desktop because
this file is on the desktop and then i'm
gonna type
in streamlit run and then the name of
the application which is
my app dot py enter
and that's it okay so it's gonna spawn
up a web server
and this is what you're gonna see a
simple stock price
application okay so let me show you side
by side
the code and the application
all right here so here the simple stock
price app
here is the heading and since it is one
hashtag it means that it is
having the heading one style h1 in html
language but if we have two
then it will be a bit smaller so let's
save it and then it detects that the
source file has changed and then
we should select always run and then we
should select
always rerun and so it's going to update
to be a bit smaller as you will see here
and if i
add additional hashtag and save it it
will be even smaller
okay so i'm gonna change it back to one
hashtag and so it is heading one let me
try okay so let's maybe
modify this a bit in markdown manner so
closing price i'm gonna make it bold
volume i'm gonna make it bold
and an italic see so you could customize
the style in markdown style
so you want to refer to the markdown
cheat sheets and i think this is a good
one to refer to
so the markdown cheat sheet by adam
pritchard
and it has everything that you would
ever wanted to know about markdown
alright so you could add cool stuff in
here
you could add lists unordered lists
you could add links you could add images
you could add tables okay
like for example let me copy this
and then i'm gonna just put it here
all right so it's a table
okay very neat right okay but let's
delete it
for simplicity so the ticker symbol is
google so we can even customize the
ticker symbol to be
other values as well so let's say aapl
for apple save it and then this is the
price
for apple so i could update this like
that
okay as you can see it will update
automatically
to the website okay so this is the date
range
that are shown in this line chart and
this is the actual line chart
so if i wanted to delete one of them and
then save it then only one will be shown
okay and let's say that i wanna
write something in
okay so i'm gonna write here the heading
one
closing price maybe make it heading two
all right and i'm going to do the same
for
the volume
and see we'll see this is the customized
version
okay so if you zoom into mail you could
even do that as well this is a
interactive chart
and if you want to zoom to the original
version you would just double click on
it
right same thing here just double click
on it
and it'll go to the original state
and so there you have it a data driven
web application
in just a few lines of code
do you want to build a bioinformatics
web application if you answered yes then
you want to watch this video to the end
because in this video i'm going to show
you how you could build a very simple
bioinformatics web application in python
and without further ado we're starting
right now
so the bioinformatics web application
that we are going to build today is
called the
dna nucleotide count web application
okay so let's fire up the terminal
and let me activate my conda for python
click on the activate and the
environment is called the
dp dp is standing for data professor
and so let me go to the folder where i
have my streamlet web application files
cd desktop cd streamlit cd dna
okay and so we have a total of three
files here and so the aromatase.fasta
is a example data file but actually
we're not using it to build the web
application
so essentially we're going to have only
the python
dna dot py and also the
dna logo.jpg and the dna logo will be
displayed
in the web application right here online
number 14.
so let me fire up the web app so i'm
going to have to
type in streamlit and then
run and then the name of the app which
is dna dash
app dot py
okay and so for those of you who don't
have streamlight installed you could
install it
via pip so you could simply do a pip
install streamlit okay and so
the web application is right here so
this image here is the
logo and the logo looks like this let me
show it here
the logo is right here so for this logo
i've drawn it using the good notes
application in ipad alright so let's
have a look at the web application
and let me show it side by side
[Music]
okay
let me also increase the font size here
all right there you go so it's bigger
for you guys
and right here too okay there you go so
it's a lot bigger now
okay so let's take a look at the code
here so the first couple of lines here
we're going to be importing the
necessary libraries for this web
application
so on line number five here we're going
to make use of the data frame
from the pandas library and the basis of
this web application
we'll be using the streamlit library so
we're going to import streamlit as well
and for the graph here we're going to
make use of the alt air
or altair library and then for
displaying the logo we're going to have
to import
from pil import image okay so
the block of code here from line number
10 to
24 we're essentially going to show the
dna logo
so we're going to create a variable
called image
which contains the name of the logo and
then we're going to display the image
here
and then we're going to display it by
allowing the image to
expand to the column width here so it
will expand to the column width and then
we're going to print out the
header here dna nucleotide count web
application
right here shown in bold and then we're
going to have a short explanation
this app counts the nucleotide
composition of the
query dna and then the three asterisks
here will be
showing the hr line so the hr line is
essentially the
horizontal line here okay and so the
next block of code here
will be showing the text box here
the dna text box here enter dna sequence
so st.header will be showing the header
here
enter dna sequence which is right here
and then the text box here will be
displayed using
the st.text area okay and then we're
going to have the height to be 250
so if you want it to be a bit smaller
then you could adjust the number here
and so you can see that when the height
is 150 the height is smaller and if it's
350
it'll be bigger so let's have it at 250.
okay and sequence input here this is the
sample dna sequence shown here so if i
modify the name here
the name will be modified here and the
slash n here
is the new line so if i don't have it
here then there won't be a new line
okay
like for example you could you know
import your dna sequence
[Music]
and then command enter and then you're
going to get a different output
okay and so
upon reading in the sequence here
st.text area
the input here in the text box will be
provided or assigned
to the sequence variable and then for
the sequence
variable we're going to split the lines
so each of the line here will be split
okay
by splitting it means that it will
create a
list of each of the lines so the first
member of the list
will be dna query and then the second
line will be the
second member of the list third line
will be the third member and the fourth
line will be the fourth member of the
list
and to provide this even clearer
let me show you
not there but here
all right right here so you're gonna see
here that
when we use sequence and then we use dot
split
lines we see that each of the line here
line number one
line number two line number three line
number four
will be shown here as four members here
of the list
one two three four okay
and the lines will be indicated by the
backslash
n which is the syntax for newline which
is also right here
so this is the equivalent of pressing
the enter key
on the keyboard as so like that okay
that's a new line all right so let me
take that out
and so we're gonna skip the first line
here sequence
one colon which means that we're going
to read lines number two
onwards because the first line will be
the name
of the sequence right here which we
don't want
because we want to compute the dna
composition
using from lines number one onward i
mean
index number one onwards which
corresponds to the
second member of the list the index of
one
onwards so that means index number one
two and three
until the end right because the n is
line number three index number three
okay so
line number forty will essentially skip
the sequence name
because the index of the sequence name
is zero
so it's gonna skip this and we're gonna
slice
and select lines number one i mean index
number one onwards
so here we're gonna slice or select in
the bracket here
index number one onwards meaning that
index number one here
onwards until the end and it has a total
of three additional lines
index one in x2 and x3 and then it will
be assigned to
the same name sequence okay so let's
show it here again
as you can see the name is now gone
and now we have only the sequence and we
have a total of three
members in the list now and before there
were
a total of four members including the
sequence name
as the first position but because we
have already selected
the second member onwards right here
second member onwards
second third fourth it means that word
this
it means that we're discarding the
sequence name
and so here we have only the sequence
and so it's very helpful
to have a look at the contents of the
variable
line by line so that you can see how the
input data
is being modified accordingly for each
line of code here
okay and notice that we have a total of
three members in the list and so
for the next line of code here right
here we're going to join
the three lines here together in order
to form a
long stretch of dna sequence let me show
you
what i mean
all right here so you can see that using
the dot join
sequence and then because here we're
saying that we don't want any space
in between so we're gonna get one line
of sequence here
okay so the three lines shown here will
be combined
into one and notice here that we have
two quotation marks
if i add a space here there will be
a space added right here space added
here
space edit here okay or we can even make
it a new line for example to show you
how the data is being modified
okay and becomes a new line or if we say
we want to add a dot
it will add a dot right here see it will
add a dot here
and it will add a dot here
so we don't want to add anything here
we're gonna just have the two quotation
marks
close together and it will be one long
stretch of line here
okay and now we have the dna sequence
that is pre-processed and ready for
computation so
let me delete this again
all right let's take a look further
so here line number 46 is the comment
for prince the input dna sequence
so the dna sequence that we see here
will be printed here
in the input header dna query so this is
the input that we have
already pre-processed by joining all of
the lines together so the three lines
will be joined
so as you can see initially we read in
the dna sequence here
and then we deleted the first line
by discarding it where we only take into
consideration
the nucleotide information here and then
we join it together into a single
line as shown here and now
let's proceed to line number 50 dna
nucleotide count
heather is output dna nucleotide count
right here
so under this heading we're going to
show you the four
different ways that you could display
the output
so before displaying the output we're
going to do some computation
so in the first method here print
dictionary
all right so we're going to use the
subheader so the subheader will be
slightly smaller than the header
the font size will be slightly smaller
all right and here
lines number 55 to 62
we're going to create a custom function
for counting
the dna nucleotide from the sequence so
here def and then the name of the
function
and then the input argument seq
and then we're going to create a d
variable which is a
dictionary and then it's going to
contain four members here
atgc and for a we're going to count
the number of a in the dna sequence and
for t
we're going to count the number of t
using the dot count
function same thing for g same thing for
c and then at the end it will return
the d variable and so the d variable
will be a dictionary
containing the name of the nucleotide
atg
or c along with the count of each of the
nucleotide
so essentially it will be a dictionary
like for example
a 59 t 43 g
52 c 56 so 59 43
52 56 means that there are a total of 59
adenine here 59 of a here 43 of t
i mean 52 of g guanine and 56
of c the cytosine okay so we're finished
here now
we're up to here okay
and we're displaying the x which is
essentially
applying the dna custom function and the
input sequence
and then we assign it to x here and i
believe that we didn't use
the label or values here let's save it
all right and so okay and so let's
move on to the next block of code here
number two
print the text print the text okay
so let's say that we want to print in
human readable form
because previously it looks like a
dictionary right
so not so friendly for the end user
so let's say that we want to print out
the text here we want to say
there are 59 adenine there are 43
thymine there are 52 adenine oh no i
mean guanine it's typo
let me do it
so i guess i copy and paste it
okay so the abbreviation all right so
the second part is finished now
let's move on to the third part display
the data frame all right so here we're
displaying it as a data frame and so
essentially there are two columns
the nucleotide and the count and so this
block of code here
we're going to create a data frame from
the dictionary function
and then we're going to rename the
column because at default it will become
zero here let me show you
[Music]
it will become zero so we're gonna
relabel zero to become count
okay
okay and so as you can see this block of
code here will give you this
data frame and this data frame will be
used for creating the following bar
charts
in number four display the bar chart and
so
for the fourth one here we're going to
be making the bar chart
and we're going to make use of the
altair library so line number 87 will
print the
subheader lines number 88 to 91 it will
create the actual plot and then in lines
number 92
through 94 we're going to adjust the
width of the bars
because by default the bars will be
pretty thin let me show you
right here yeah so it's pretty thin so
we're gonna adjust it to be 80
which should look a bit better
all right so it looks a bit better and
notice here that the chart
are assigned to the p variable and then
in order to
show the plot or the chart we're going
to put it inside as the input argument
to the st.right function so that it
becomes
a streamlit object okay and so there you
have it a very simple
bioinformatics web application feel free
to modify this
to be another web application in
bioinformatics
or for any industry as well because the
code is quite
applicable and you could use it as a
template for building your own
personal data science project
okay so this video is the fifth part of
the
streamlit tutorial series where i go
into
detail step by step on how you could
build a data science web application
and so let's have a quick recap in the
first part i have shown you the first
web app that you could build using
streamlit in python and with that
application you're
obtaining data dynamically from the y
finance
library where it will retrieve stock
data directly from the yahoo finance
and then we're going to make a simple
line chart in the second part we have
built a simple
iris predictor where we employed machine
learning
algorithm and in the third part we used
the machine learning algorithm
to classify penguins into one of three
species and so the concept is similar to
the iris predictor
but with a notable difference in that
the input parameters have
three additional ordinal or qualitative
variables so that required a little bit
more data pre-processing
in order to encode the ordinal features
into
binary form and in the fourth part i've
shown you how you could deploy your
data science web application onto the
cloud so that other people and your
friends
can have access to your data science web
application
and we did that by deploying the
application
onto hiroku and so today it is the fifth
part of the streamlet tutorial series
and we're going to combine two prior
videos
in the development of a web application
today so essentially we're going to
dynamically retrieve data from the
internet
by doing web scraping of the
basketballreference.com website
and so after we have web scraped the
data we're going to do some
data filtering and so all of this will
be done right inside
streamlit and so finally we're going to
perform a simple exploratory data
analysis by creating a simple
heat map and so all of this in less than
70
lines of code and so without further ado
we're starting right now
okay so the code that we're going to use
today is called basketball
underscore app dot py and upon opening
the
code we're going to see this so all of
this code is
less than 70 lines of code and so this
is also including
empty spaces as well so if we are to
delete all of the empty spaces i would
think it is
approximately 60 lines of code and so a
lot to be done here
and it will occupy just a few lines of
code here so the data science
web application that we are building
today is called the
nba player stats explorer and so before
we take a deep dive
into the code let's try to run this code
and let's have a look at the web
application so let's close the file for
a moment
and let's open up a command prompt so if
you are on a windows type in cmd
if you are on a mac or a ubuntu you want
to open up your terminal
and so this is only going to work on my
computer
because i'm going to type in conda
activate dp
dp being the name of the conduct
environment that is installed on my
computer so if you have a conda
environment installed on your computer
you can activate that particular
conda environment so you could type in
conda activate and then the name of your
environment
for example if the name of your
environment is my env
then you would type in conda activate my
env
but because on my computer it's called
dp i'm going to use conda activate dp
and so the lengthy explanation
is due to the prior videos i have been
noticing that there have been some
misunderstanding that you will have to
type in conda activate dp which is not
the case because
if your computer is using just normal
python you could just
proceed with following the tutorial here
however if you're using conda then you
will
want to activate your own environment
okay so let's continue
so now i have activated my conda
environment i'm going to
change directory to the desktop and then
to the streamlit folder which is where
all of my data are residing in
so for your case you want to change the
directory to
where all of your files are located
particularly for the streamlid tutorial
so the links to this
code will be provided in the description
down below so you want to check that out
okay here it is so the name of the app
is basketball underscore app dot py
so a point in note for the first time
that we're running this
basketball application you will see
some error message and the error message
will tell us that
some libraries are missing and so that
we will have to install the prerequisite
library in python so let's have a look
at this together so that we could
overcome this error together
okay so you want to type in streamlid
run basketball underscore app
dot py and so we're gonna see this pop
up browser
and so here it says that xml not found
please install it so let's close this
and then we are going to install lxml
contact tp
pip install lxm
lxml
okay so it's installed let's
head over back
so notice that i could type fast here
because i
type in the first few characters of the
folder name
and then i hit on the tab button and so
the tab button will auto complete the
folder name for example i type in
streamlit run
ba or just b and then tab it will
autocomplete the name for me
let's run the application again
okay so it seems to work now and so
this is our nba player stats explorer
web application that we are going to
build today
so let's have a look at the general
characteristic of this web app so you're
going to see that on the
sidebar on the left we're going to have
three input parameters
so the first one is the year of the data
that you want to have a look at
and then the second parameter will be
the team and so
notice here that you could select
multiple teams and by default
it will select all of the teams for you
and then you could take on the teams
that you don't want
and then the results will be updated on
the fly
so notice that whenever i click on the x
mark here you will see that the number
of rows will
reduce right from 683
to 665.
and so the third parameter of the input
is the position
of the players so we're going to have
the five traditional positions here
center power forward small forward point
guard and shooting guard and so to the
right here which is the main panel
so here we have the name of the web app
and then some description
and then we're gonna have some header
here followed by the description of the
data dimension
and then we're gonna display the data
frame of our data set
so this data set will be downloaded
spontaneously
from basketballreference.com and so
we're gonna use pandas to do the
web scraping and then it will do some
simple
data filtering so i'm going to show you
in the code in just a moment
and so once we have done some simple
data filtering we're going to display
the data accordingly
and the data frame that you see here we
will be able to export the data as
a csv file and finally we will also
have a look at the intercorrelation heat
map of the input parameters
and so this is the exploratory data
analysis
that i have mentioned so we're going to
do only one plot here so
please feel free if you want to explore
by including
other data visualization plots in your
web app so in this web application i
made it so that
the heat map will be hidden unless you
click on the button and upon clicking on
the button you will see the
heat map coming up okay
so pretty cool right so let's now have a
look
in the code shall we let's open up the
atom editor file open
file and then basketball app
all right so let's have a look at the
code side by side
okay here so in the first six lines of
the code we're going to import the
necessary libraries
so we're gonna import the streamlit
library because we're using streamlit to
build the web app we're gonna import
pandas because we use pandas to handle
the data frame and also to perform the
web scraping we use the base64 library
in order to handle the data
download for the csv file because it's
going to encode the
ascii to byte conversion and so finally
we're using matplotlib
seaborn and numpy in order to create the
heat map plot
okay so let's have a look further on
line number eight st.title is the name
of the web app and the name of the web
app is
nba player stats explorer which is right
here on the right
and then some description of the web app
is provided here
so you will notice that we're using
markdown language
so this description here will correspond
to this
line the two bullet point will be
corresponding to the two asterisks here
and the both texts will be corresponding
to the two asterisks here and so we're
also including the data source link
which is basketballreference.com which
is where we are
downloading the data and so the
following code here are for the sidebar
so this is the header name of the
sidebar so we're using the
st.sidebar.header
and then in the input argument we're
using user input features
which is right here user input features
and then
in the following line on line number 17
selected year
is the name of the variable and then
we're going to use this
line of code here to display the years
that we want to see the data for
so we're making it as a drop down menu
so we're using the select box function
and so as the import argument the first
argument that you see here
is name year and so year is right here
so if we change this
a bit save it and then we say always
rerun
and then you're gonna see that the
question mark appears as well so if we
take it out
save it have a look back then the
question mark disappears
okay and then the following input
argument here is
we're going to create a range of numbers
so we're going to have
1950 until 2019 which is right here
and then we are going to reverse the
list of the numbers
because it's going to start from 1950 in
1951 1952
and then at the bottom it will be 2019
and so i use the reversed and then
convert it into a list
in order for it to display 2019 at the
top right otherwise it will display 1950
at the top and then it will be the
default value
and so notice that whenever you change
the year here the corresponding data
frame will also change
so all of these data are downloaded on
the fly
on demand upon clicking on the input
parameters
so nothing is stored locally on the
server side
okay and then in this block of code here
it will be performing the web scraping
and also some data pre-processing
and this is taken from a previous
tutorial video where i will also provide
the link in the description of this
video
as well where we perform a simple web
scraping
of the basketballreference.com website
and then the only thing that we're using
for the web scripting is only one line
which is
pd.read.html so it's going to read the
html file
particularly the data is in the form of
a table therefore pandas can easily read
the data from the table
which is inside the html file and then
we're going to use it
by dropping some of the redundant header
which is present throughout
the table data and then after removing
those
we will perform some simple deletion of
some
index column here called rk because it
will be redundant with the index
provided normally by pandas and then
finally we will
display the pre-processed data and then
on line number 29
we're going to make use of this custom
function load data
and then the selected year is the input
argument which is the
variable here selected year so the
custom function
load data will retrieve the nba player
stash data
by using the input argument which is
provided in the selected year
variable and the selected year variable
is accepting input
from the drop down menu here so whenever
you say 2019
the value of 2019 will go into the load
data 2019 which is the input argument
so we're going to retrieve the data for
2019 and etc for other years that are
selected
okay so lines number 31-3233 we're going
to allow the user to select the teams
that we are going to display in the data
frame
and so line number 32 is the variable
called sorted
unique team and so here we're going to
use the
player stats data frame particularly the
team
column and then we're only going to
display the unique
values okay and then after that we're
going to sort
the team alphabetically and then it will
be displayed here right starting from a
until w here and then on lines number 35
36 37 we're also going to allow the user
to select the positions
and so here we have specified the five
traditional positions
okay so let's have a look at the import
argument of the
multi-select function so this
multi-select function will allow us
to display all of the possible values
inside the team variable and the
position
variable and the second and third input
argument here
will be telling the multi-select what
are the possible values that we are
going to be using
so the second input argument here will
be using all of the team names
and all of the position names as
provided on lines number 36
and 32 and then the third input argument
for both of them we're going to also use
as default value
which we will be displaying here to be
the same thing so essentially
we're keeping the second and third
argument to be the same so this means
that
we're going to display all of the
possible values
in here so let me show you what if i do
a simple slicing
of only the first index number so i will
be showing you only one
position which is the first position
right here center so if i do the same
thing here
i'm going to show only the first team
which is atlanta right so here you're
gonna see that the options are
showing only one value so if i change
this to two
or three just some arbitrary number
and so you're gonna see that these
arbitrary numbers that i have provided
will show you
the input values as the default
so if i just say everything
we're gonna use everything so therefore
the second and third will be the same
okay so let's save it
okay so here we have all of the possible
values
so let's say if we change the year to
2018 you're going to notice that
it's going to be loading the data for
the first time and so
it will say running load data function
however
if we switch back to 2019 where the data
has already been loaded and so
it will use the catch data and so if i
switch back to 2018
the data has already been loaded just a
few moments ago
and so the data will be instantaneously
displayed
however if i select 2017 where the data
has never been loaded before
it will load for the first time and
you're gonna see running load data
function
and then it will catch the data okay
right here
in the line 20 we're using the add sign
st.catch before the load data function
and therefore whenever we select a new
year
it will run for the first time and then
it will make a catch of that data so
that the second time we
make use of it it will be performing
much
quicker and all of the underlying data
will be updated as well
filtering data okay here let's have a
look on line number 40.
so line number 40 will be filtering data
based
on the input selection in the sidebar
menu
so if we select dallas
out denver out chicago out cleveland out
then these resulting input will be
dictating which rows to be shown and so
you're going to notice that the data
dimension will be updated to be 512 rows
now and so if we
take away some of it then the number of
rows will be impacted here and so
all of this is possible because of this
filtering data
part which is line number 40. so
whenever we make a selection
on the sidebar it will be in the
selected team
variable right here and also in the
selected position
variable right here which is
corresponding to
team here and position here
so whenever we update the selection
the data frame will be updated because
the selected team
variable and the selected position
variable will be updated and so
we're also going to only filter the data
and show
only the remaining input selection okay
so all of this is possible by this line
so i might make another video about
selecting data in pandas so you could do
this by
using the name of the data frame and
then you use a bracket
and then inside the bracket you put in
your condition okay so this
is very powerful and i believe that for
those of you
working with data wrangling or data
cleaning
then this filtering capability here will
be
immensely useful for your project
particularly when you are
preparing your own data set all right
lines number 42
43 and 44 will be displaying
the header here and also the
description of the data dimension and
it will be showing the data frame itself
right here so it will be showing this
df selected team data frame the one that
we have done filtering on
okay and then lines number 48 through
52. it is a custom function
called file download so the resulting
data frame that we have here
we're going to put it inside the file
download as the input argument
and therefore it will create this link
for us
download csv file so notice at the
bottom that you're going to see
a long generated code here and so this
is made possible by the
base 64 library and so it's going to
perform some encoding and decoding
okay and so all of this will be inside
this function and so
this function is brought to you by the
wonderful discussion
in this streamlit how to okay and so
let's have a look at the heat map so
lines number 56
until 68 is the heat map right here
where we click on the button and then it
shows the heat map
it is possible by this if statement
if st button and then we have the name
of the button
inside as argument and then we have all
of these lines of code as the
underlying code so st.heather is the
header here
so it's right here the header and then
we're going to have df selected team
saving it into a csv file and then we're
gonna read it back in
and so the reason is why are we doing
that because
i have been trying to create the heat
map using the
df selected team and it's not working
and
upon exporting it out as a file and then
reading it back in
it read perfectly so i think it has
something to do with the data type that
is inside the pandas data frame
but upon reading it back in there were
no issues okay and so then
we performed some intercorrelation
matrix calculation
and then we created the heat map and
using this line of code here we created
this
heat map where half of it are not shown
because they are masked
do you like football do you like data
science if you answered yes to both then
this video is for you
and today we're going to talk about how
you could merge
football and data science together and
without further ado we're starting right
now
so in this video we're going to cover
how you could build your very own
simple web application for exploring the
nfl player stats data okay so let's get
started so the first thing you want to
do is
fire up your google chrome or your
internet browser
and then you want to click on the
seasons tab go to 2019
nfl click on the team stats and
standings
and then you want to click on the player
stats and then for the standard you want
to click on rushing
and so please note that the data that
we're going to be using today will be
based on the rushing data
and if you would like to use other then
please feel free to play around with it
and so you want to click on the rushing
okay and so we're going to be taken to
this page here and so you're going to
see the player stats right here
and so we're going to be scraping the
data from this website
and so let us copy this url
all right and so now we're going to fire
up the terminal
and as always i'll be activating my
conda environment
so on your own computer if you have
conduct installed
and you have a contact environment then
you could activate your own content
environment but if you don't have any
then you don't have to do anything
so i like to use conda because it allows
me to contain
all of the libraries and packages and
dependency in a self-contained manner so
that it doesn't ruin the other
project that i'm working on on the same
computer
so i'm going to desktop here
streamlight folder going to the football
all right and so that's the
file that we have football app dot py
okay and so we're gonna take a look at
the code in atom
and let me also fire up the web app as
well
okay and so this is the web application
that you're seeing here
and on the left you're going to see a
collapsible side panel
and so the side panel here will have a
total of three input
section so the first one will be taking
the user input of which
year you want the data to be from so
here we're using a default of the year
2019
and if we click down on it you will
notice that it will start from 1990 and
so we could change that year
and i'll be showing you that in just a
moment and the teams will be
detected directly from the data frame
here
and then the position is taken from the
pos
column here okay and so notice that this
web app that i'm going to be
demonstrating today we have not yet done
any data cleaning and so we're using
only the completed
data so you're going to see that there
are a total of 117
rows here so i'll be leaving it to you
as a hobby project for you to clean the
data and let's see how
bigger the data set will become so let
me show you
what does the raw data looks like okay
so that's the raw data
okay and as you can see there are a
total of about 344
rows here versus 117 which is the
complete data
okay so it's clean here the one that we
have
so let me hide this again
okay and let's take a look further at
the functionality of the web
app that we have here so if you click on
the intercorrelation heat map you're
going to be
seeing the intercorrelation of the
variables here
okay so let's take a line by line
explanation of the code here
so the first six lines of code will be
importing the necessary libraries that
we are going to be using today
and so the first one is the streamlit
because it allows us to build this
essentially this web app and then we're
going to import pandas as pd
because of the data frame that we're
using here we're going to be using
base64
because of here the functionality to
download the data
as a csv file so it will be essentially
encoding it
and decoding it and so here we're going
to be making use of matplotlib
dot pi plot as plt and also the import
seaborn as sns so we're going to use
both of them together to make the
histogram plot that we see right here
and so here as you can see we're using
numpy
in the creation of this histogram plot
all right and so now let's move on to
line number eight line number eight here
is the title of the web app
and the title is nfl football stats
rushing explorer lines number 10 through
14
is right here the explanation of the web
app
this app performed simple web scraping
of
nfl football player stats data focusing
on rushing
and so the python libraries that we're
using is included right here
and actually is not yet complete we also
have numpy
we also have matplotlib and
seaborn and so the data source is coming
from theprofootballreference.com
and so notice that a couple of minutes
ago i've shown you
how i've copied this url link
okay this link at the top here all right
and then i've pasted right here
as a reference so in the load data
function
notice that for the url right here
this is the url that we are going to
web script the data and notice that here
we're setting the date
in the range of 1990 to 2020
and so notice that in the url you have
the first
component here which is essentially
right here the first segment
and then the second segment will be the
year which we are going to do
programmatically
by replacing it with a string of the
year and then we're going to add
forward slash rushing.htm right here
with the forward slash
and so essentially this will give us
this url
right here if 2019 is selected here
but if we select 2018 then
this becomes 2018 and the data will then
be updated
and here we set the header to be one
in order to retrieve the data set here
so this is the function for doing the
web scraping
using the pandas library and so as you
can see that the web scripting is done
in
only one line of code here and then the
other lines we're going to
essentially be pre-processing the data
set
meaning that we're dropping some
redundant headers
or we're also dropping some repetitive
columns and values etc
and then finally we're going to be
assigning the load data
to the player stats variable
and then we're going to be sorting the
team and
you're going to see the sorted team
right here in the user input features
here
okay which is line number 33 and 34.
so after we sorted the team and we're
showing the unique values because
here you're going to see that in the raw
data the team values will be
repetitive and so here we're sorting
according to the unique values and so
we're going to see only
unique values of the team names here and
in sorted order
all right and then lines number 36
through 38
is going to be right here the position
so here we have said it to be
rb qb wr fb and te okay and
we're also using it as a multi-select
meaning that you could select multiple
values at the same time
or you could just delete it and then
select the ones that you like
okay
okay you could add one by one
the values that you like okay
and then aligns number 40 and 41 here
we're going to be filtering the data
based on the input of the sidebar
of the team selection and the position
selection so line number 41 will be
essentially filtering
the data frame that we're seeing right
here based on our
input selection the team and the
position
lines number 43 through 45
we're going to be displaying the header
called display player stats of selected
team
right here and also the data dimension
in a normal text underneath the header
and then the actual data frame will be
displayed according to line number 45
right here
okay and then lines 47 through 55
it will allow us to download this data
frame into a
csv file so let's download it
and as a recall we're using the base64
library in order to perform the
encoding decoding of the data and so
you're going to see that the data is
downloaded into this file
and then the remaining part of the code
will essentially allow us to make the
heat map
shown right here if you click on the
button enter correlation heat map
you click on it and then you will be
seeing this heat map here
of the intercorrelation between the
variables
and so this block of code will allow you
to make the heat map
and so as you can see here all of this
is just under 70 lines of code
and it allows you to build a very simple
data driven
web application for retrieving or web
scraping
the nfl football player stats data
in this video i'm going to show you how
you could build a data driven web
application in python for web scraping
s p 500 stock prices and without further
ado we're starting right now
okay so the first thing that you want to
do is fire up your terminal
so today i'm going to use a microsoft
windows and then i'm going to as
always activate my conda environment
and the files are on the desktop and so
i'm going to provide you the links to
the files described in this tutorial so
you want to check out the video
description
sp 500
okay so you're going to see that the
only file that we're going to use
is the sp 500-app.py
so let's have a look at that
and before doing that let's also open up
the web app
streamlet run sp 500
app.py
all right so here we are okay so you're
going to see that in the web app we're
going to have a sidebar
on the left and here we're going to have
two input features the first one will
allow us to select the sectors
and the second one will allow us to
select the number of companies
and the data for the names of the
company in the s p
500 was taken from wikipedia and so i'm
going to show you
where we got that the links is right
here
okay so the table that we're going to
web scrape is this table here
so we're going to see that it has the
symbol for the company
the name of the company and other
information like
the sector and the sub industry sector
the headquarter location and also the
founding dates of the company
and notice that there will be two tables
and the second table will be here but
for the purpose of this tutorial we're
going to use only
this table here so before we
take a dive into the web application
let's have a look
at how did i created the essential
functions
for making this web app
so let me first go to google collab
so let me expand this a bit
okay so here is the details of how we're
going to
make the web application so firstly
we're going to create a function
a custom function that will allow us to
web script the data
from wikipedia so here we're defining a
function called load data
and then the first thing is we're going
to put in the url
of the s p 500 which is essentially
right
here and then we know that we're going
to take this table so the prerequisite
of
web scraping using pandas read html
function
is that the data must be in a table so
if data is
in a paragraph like this it wouldn't
work
so you would need something like
beautiful soup and selenium in order to
do that
and because the data is organized in a
very simple table manner here
we're going to just specify that we want
the first table
so we're going to specify this to be
zero okay and then the
data will go into the df which we will
return here
and upon running this cell
let's do it
so you're going to see that the web
script data is provided in the df
variable here and it looks very nice
let's take a look at the sectors here in
the fourth column
sector so we're gonna select the
sector column from the df data frame
and then we're going to take out the
unique count
how many unique sectors are there and so
we're going to see that there are a
total of
11 sectors comprising of industrials
healthcare information technology
communication
services consumer discretionary
utilities
financials materials real estate
consumer staples energy
okay and then so let's say that we're
going to aggregate the data by grouping
them according to the
specific sector name which is comprised
of 11 different sectors
and then we're going to show only the
first company for each of the sector
of the 11 sector so we're going to see
that for each of the 11 sector in the
first
index column here we're going to see the
first example
of the company name so this represents
the first
company for each of the 11 sectors
and let's do a descriptive statistics of
this sector
variable so we're going to see that
there are a total of 26 companies
in the communication services 60 company
in the consumer
discretionary 32 company and consumer
staples let's take a look at only the
health care
so let's take a look at only the health
care sector so we're going to use
the get group function and then here
we're going to see
63 companies
so all of the companies here are
belonging to the healthcare sector
okay so this first part are data derived
directly
from the wikipedia website and now let's
do a
second part where we take the names of
the s p
500 and then we're going to retrieve the
stock price
data from the y finance library in
python
so the first thing is to install the y
finance library
okay and so now we have installed it and
now we're going to import it
as yf okay and so
here these are the list of the company
symbols
from the df data frame that we have got
above where we web script
from wikipedia so here all of the
company names are here
and now we're going to retrieve the
stock data so using the example code
from this
url directly from the y finance
pipe project web page there is a
function to download the
stock price data and here we're going to
use the
period of ytd which is the year to date
so this will be from the beginning of
the year right until
right now which is october 6 2020
and then the ticker will be all of the
data in the s
p 500 so there's going to be more than
500 companies
here and then the data will be grouped
by the ticker which is the
symbol of the company and then
everything else we're just going to
leave it as
default all right so let's run it
so this should take a moment because
it's going to download all of the stock
price
data from the y finance and it will be
placed into the data data frame
and note that the interval is one day
which is also the default and you could
feel free to change the interval to like
one minute two minute
but then this will generate a lot of
data or you can make it in
monthly intervals as well or even weekly
intervals
all right and so it apparently is
finished let's have a look further
so it's saying that two companies could
not fetch the data
from bf and brk
and 505 have been completed out of the
507
okay so this is the stock price data and
you can see that the
price information are grouped according
to the ticker symbol here
and then you could easily retrieve
specific companies by
specifying it in the bracket okay
and then you get the data that you need
192 rows because
it is starting since january until right
now this is october 192 days
okay and so what we're going to do here
is we're going to move the date
to be one of the column as you can see
that now the date is part of the column
here and
we want to make use of the closing price
so our new data frame will contain
two columns the date and also the close
price so you could feel free to play
around with the price data
if you want to use the open or the high
or the low price
but for this tutorial we're only going
to stick to the closing price
all right and now we're going to do the
fun part we're going to make a plot of
it
and so this is the plot of the closing
price
and in the x-axis is the dates and the
closing price will be in the y-axis
so you're gonna see that the price is
dipped around april
and then it kind of went up and if you
compare from beginning of the year
until right now the price is about 18
higher okay so let's do the same thing
but then we're going to make a custom
function
and the reason for making a custom
function is that it's going to make our
life
and the reason for making this custom
function is that it's going to make our
life much easier
because we're only going to specify the
name of the symbol that's the input
argument
like right here and then it's going to
make the plot for you
like here that we don't have to copy the
entire
code here then modify it to suit the
name of the
ticker symbol so we're going to make a
general
helper function
let's do it here so the
custom function that we're making is
called the price plot
and then we're gonna use price plot and
then the input argument will be the
ticker symbol we could change the
company if you like
all right and then you're to see that
the price is
it's updated now and then
the beautiful part about this is that we
can even run it as a for loop
so the price plot will be inside the for
loop
and then we're going to iterate through
all of the company names but then here
we're going to select only the first 10
companies
okay i have to run
oh okay we updated the name
here df okay we're using the same name
then we have to
take the name here
we have to rerun
the load data function
okay and now it will be reassigned to
the df
because previously we have overwritten
the df
variable name and it is lacking the
symbol column
right here
right here we have overwritten the same
name
so i think we should call this something
else
let's call it df2
and this will have to be df2
right let's do it again this is df2
and then
okay it works again
it should work now because we have
already run the symbol
here
df symbol
all right it's working and we want the
first 10 companies
all right 1 2
3 4 5
6 7 8 9
10. all right there we have it
and so the proof of concept is now
working and we have tried the proof of
concept
directly on the google code lab so the
great part of making this proof of
concept on the google code lab is that
we could be quite flexible in working on
different computers
and using the same google code lab and
once we're finished with that then we
could
start the production phase where we will
deploy it to the
web application in streamlit and so now
we're ready to deploy it
onto streamlit and let's do that
and there you go we have already
deployed it to streamlid a couple of
minutes ago
all right and so let's take a look at
this web application
so in the user input here we're going to
have the name of the
sectors where we could essentially
select the sector here
and then we also are able to select the
number of companies that we want to
show in the show plot area so if we have
two companies
then the show plot area will also have
two buffs
up to a maximum of five and the maximum
of five could be changed to another
value that you would like
okay and so i'm using five just an
arbitrary number and here we have five
plots
and the great thing about this is that
you could also modify this web
application
so that it will be tailored to your own
country's stock price
so let me know in the comments how
you're making use of this
or how you are modifying this web
application
and if you would like to share your
creation let me know and i could share
it
on one of the tutorial videos where i
could show how to recreate the web
application that you have made
and so drop me an email and the email
will be provided
in the description of the video okay and
so let's take a line by line look
at the explanation of the code so here
the first
seven lines will be importing the
necessary libraries
so first one is the streamlit the second
one is pandas
and we're gonna use streamlit because
this web application
is built on top of the streamlit library
and we're going to use the pandas
because of the data frame
by which we are showing the data and
then the base 64
will allow us to encode the data so that
we are able to provide it as
a csv file and here we're going to use
matplotlib for making the plots
and apparently we didn't use cborn and
so let me delete that
and also from here
all right and we also have y finance
we're gonna add it here
all right and so that left us with a
total of
six library and then the next one is
numpy and why finance
let's see did we use numpy
no we did not use numpy sorry because i
was
using a previous web application as the
template for this one
so even less now we're having only
a total of five libraries so why
finance the fifth one is going to allow
us to retrieve the stock price
for the s p 500 and so you're going to
see here that we are making use of only
five python libraries all right and so
the st.title
will be the function that we're going to
use to make the title of the web
application here
s p 500 app shown as a both text here
and then we're going to make use of the
markdown
function in order to display the details
of the web application
and also the libraries that we're using
in python and also the data source
which is taken from wikipedia and then
we have the st.sidebar
dot header it means that we're going to
create
a header called user input features and
then we're going to put it inside the
sidebar to the left here on line number
19
we're going to say that we want to catch
the data if it has already been run for
the first time
so that the second time or subsequent
time it wouldn't need to redownload the
data again and again
and so it only needs to do that only
once for the first time
so lines number 20 to 24 is a custom
function
that we have taken directly from the
google code lab where we have
experimented
with the creation of this web scraper of
the s p
500 data and so we just paste it right
here and then we're going to assign the
web script data into the df data frame
and then we're going to group by the
sector name which is right here we're
going to group by the
it's not shown here okay right here
we're going to group by the sector names
on line number 27 and then lines number
30 and 31 we're going to display
the sector name as an option where you
could select
you want to select only particular one
here we are only selecting communication
services and so we're going to see that
there are 26
companies here or we could also add one
by one
the companies that we like
i mean the sectors of the company that
we like
all right and then line number 34 is
only going to filter out
from the entire data frame the sectors
that you
have selected in the user input feature
panel here
so it's going to use the is in function
in order to
see which are coming from the selected
sectors
right here three selected sector which
is right here selective sector
coming from the sidebar and multi select
function
multi select means here we have multi
selection
and now the data will be in the df
selected
sector and then we're going to write it
out here in the st
data frame and the input argument is df
selected sector which is coming from
here
and it's filtering all data belonging to
the three
selected sectors here or it could be
four
right here okay and in lines number 37
it's going to write out the dimension
right here number of rows and number of
columns
and the st.header will be the function
to
display the header here
all right and lines number 42 until 46
is going to be the custom function to
allow us to decode
encode the data and make the csv file of
this data available for download right
here
and then you get access to the csv data
all right
and then the second part is the finance
data that i have shown you
just a moment ago on the google code lab
and so here we're going to make use of
the
constant function that we have already
done just a moment ago
and then for this example we're just
going to limit it to about 10 companies
otherwise it might have taken longer to
create the web application
okay and so let's have a look further
and then the custom function to make the
plot was also taken from the google
co-lab
and so lines number 52 until 61
will download the data of the stock
price directly from y finance
lines number 63 until 73
is the custom function to create the
plot that we're going to see here
in the show plot okay in line number 75
it is the slider for you to select the
number of companies
so if you want to make it into 10 then
you could do so as well
multiply that to be 10 and then the
number here will then be 10 and now
you could have 10 plus
okay you could have 10 plots now
and make sure to play around with this
number as well
make sure that this number is greater
than
this number okay because it will be the
total number of
stock price data that you're going to
have
let me change it back to five and let's
say that you don't want to hide the
plots here you just want to show it
you could hide that function the if
let's see
it's indented
okay let's see again
all right and now you have the plots
immediately
if this is 10 then
you're going to get the 10 plus right
here
okay
do you like cryptocurrency do you like
data science
if you answered yes to both questions
then this video is for you
because today i'm going to show you how
you could build a cryptocurrency
price web application and without
further ado
we're starting right now okay so the
first thing that you want to do
is fire up your terminal
and then for me i have to activate my
conda environment
and you could do the same for your own
environment as well
and i'm going to the desktop because
that's where i keep my files
for the streamlit tutorials
and i'm having the data in the
crypto price folder
all right and so in here you'll notice
that we'll have
two files the crypto app itself and the
logo
so let's open up the web application
so i have to run streamlit run
crypto price app dot py
all right and here you go this is the
web application that we are going to be
building today
and this is the cryptocurrency logo
that i have drawn and it is the logo.jpg
file
so to the left here is the input
parameters
in the side panel so here you can select
the currency
for the price at default it will be
using the usd
and you have a selection of three
choices usd
btc or eth
and then here we'll be listing the 100
top cryptocurrency
okay and then here
it will ask for the option to
select how many top cryptocurrency
should be displayed
in the data frame table here and also
in the chart here
another option that you get to select is
the percent change
for the time frame the percent change
meaning
the price change that has occurred
within the last seven days
and you have a selection of three
choices within
seven days within 24 hours or within one
hour
and then the last option here that you
could select is
do you want to sort the values in here
in the chart so you see here that
the green color will represent the price
change that is changed for the positive
gain
while some of the cryptocurrency will
have a negative
pricing here meaning that when it's
compared between
the first day and the seventh day when
the seven days selected
if the price change is negative it means
that the price has reduced
however if the price has increased then
there is a gain
okay so it's essentially the gain
of the price in green or the loss
in red okay so this is the
cryptocurrency web app that we are going
to be building today
and you can notice that here the
interface and the layout of the web
application
is full screen now because
before the web application will be
a bit centered at the middle and so
we're going to be using the
estate of the whole entire width of the
monitor here
and then the other exciting update from
streamlit is that
aside from being able to use the entire
width of the screen
we are also able to divide
our contents into multiple columns
so here we have a total of three which
is the side panel
so we're going to consider the side
panel as the first column
but also it should be noted that it
could also be collapsed
as well and then you're also going to
have the entire
screen for the content of the web
application
however for this web application we are
going to consider the sidebar as of
column
one and then we're also going to
consider this part here
the data frame as column two and then
we're going to consider the bar
chart here as column three
okay so before we would have only
a sidebar and the main content
so essentially we would be having like
two columns
however in the recent update that
streamlit has made
we are able to have multiple columns so
it could be more than three we could
make it four or we could make it five
and so the multiple column will allow us
to partition the content
in a very aesthetic way
meaning that we could group contents
that are related
in a particular column and so that would
be more visually appealing
okay so let's proceed with interpreting
the meaning of the code line by line
so let me open up the atom
okay so i'm working on an automl web
application right now
so that's going to be for the future
video
right here crypto price
okay so let me
make it half the screen
okay
so you'll be noticing here that the
first 11 lines
will be the libraries that we are going
to be using today
and so you will be noticing that we have
more than 10 lines
in this tutorial in other tutorials
we'll have like about six or five
lines meaning like five libraries to use
but in this tutorial we'll be using a
lot of libraries here
so the first one is the streamlit which
is the basis for
this web application so it's the web
framework that we are going to be using
and then we're going to be using the
logo so we're going to use the
from pil library and then we're going to
import the image
function and then we're going to make
use of the pandas in order to show the
data frame
and then import base 64 because we need
to encode decode the data in order to
allow
the user to download the cryptocurrency
data here
as a csv file
because we're making the plots here
we're needing the
matplotlib all right so actually it's
not 11
but only nine libraries okay
so probably taken it from the previous
project so i've just deleted the numpy
and the seaborn so here we're using only
the matplotlib
for the bar chart and numpy was not used
in this project
and here we're going to make use of the
beautiful soup
in order to web scrape the data from the
coin market cap website
and the basis for the web scripting was
taken from
the article from brian feng
and the article is entitled web scraping
crypto prices
with python and it is on the medium
platform
so you could click on this link in order
to read the full article by brian
so i have adapted his code in the
tutorial
in order to web scrape the
cryptocurrency price here
and make it into a web application for
our tutorial
and so the process of web scraping will
require
the request library the json and also
the
time here as well all right so
we're finished with importing the
libraries and then
it should be noted that in order to
make use of the new feature particularly
the
the page width that i have mentioned and
also the extra column
that is a new feature you need to
upgrade your streamlit
if you already have it installed on your
computer however if you haven't yet
installed it then you could install a
fresh version but in order to upgrade it
you need to
type in pip install dash dash upgrade
and then streamlit okay
and because it is a new feature
streamlit has probably
used the term beta in front of the
option here
set page config
and then the layout will be equal to
wide so this will allow us to expand the
content
to the full width of the page
so let's try commenting it out and see
what happens
all right here you go you see that when
we comment out the page width
it will be centered so you see that
there will be white space to the left
and to the right
and if we use the new feature
it will be expanding to the entire paste
width here
so we have some extra real estate
for the plots and for the data frame
and considering that we have over 100
cryptocurrency here
it's always nice to have some extra room
to show
the plot and the data frame
so we're going to make use of this new
feature here
all right and lines number 21 until
29 is going to be the
logo here which is line number 21 and 23
where we import the logo.jpg file
and we're using a width of 500 so the
width of the image will be 500 pixel
and then the title here is crypto price
app right here
crypto price app in the st.title
and then the description shown here
is in the st.markdown function
right here and then another new feature
here
is the about section
which is hidden inside the plus symbol
here if we click on it
it will expand and so this is part of
the expander
function so i'm calling it the expander
bar variable equals to st.beta expander
and so as always this is a new feature
so they include it
by using the beta in front beta
so when we're using the expander bar we
put it here
and then followed by the markdown
function
and then we include the following
bullet points here in the markdown
syntax
all right and then lines number 43 and
44
we are essentially setting the page
layout of the
web app so we're gonna create a new
variable called
column one equal to st dot sidebar
which is the sidebar here and then we're
gonna create two variables at the same
time
column two and column three column 2 is
right here the data frame
and column 3 is right here the bar plot
so notice that we have the values of 2
1 inside here it means that we want to
have the data frame column
to be two times greater than the
bar plot column meaning that the width
of the second column here will be two
times
greater than the third column
okay so you can see here that the width
of this column
is twice bigger than the third column
which is right here if it's one to one
it means that
both columns will have equal size
okay they're equal and if it's one and
then three
it means that you want to guess
you are correct and so the bar plug will
have three times
wider width than the first column
okay so we're leaving it at two to one
all right and let's hop on to the next
section here
so i'm commenting this part to be side
panel
or the sidebar plus the main panel
so column one dot header is the input
option
so this is column one meaning the
sidebar
and so input options is this one the
header here
and then currency price unit column one
dot select box select currency for price
it's right here so this select box will
allow the user to select
which cryptocurrency price unit to
use would it be usd would it be bcc or
would it be ath
and upon selecting the options
i mean the data frame will be updating
the price unit from usd right here the
price unit
from usd to bcc or to eth
and so the currency price unit will be
used
later on in the code okay i'm going to
show you later on
where it is used so this is the
ui or the user interface part
all right and so here comes the fun part
lines
will catch the following data meaning
that the second time around where you
reload the web page it will not re-web
scrape the data
so it's going to perform the web
scraping only once the first time
and it's going to keep a catch of that
for the subsequent use
so that would be beneficial for you when
you're
trying to improve this web application
incrementally without even have to
re-perform the web scraping over and
over again so that will save a lot of
resources
so as i mentioned earlier on in this
video
the web scraping of the coin market cap
data was performed
according to the article by brian feng
and you could read the full detail in
his article on medium
and so i have adapted that into this
customized function
load data
so some of the data that we're going to
web script from the coin market cap so
let's have a look at the coin market cap
here
oops okay i have to change the
coin market cap
okay let me copy the link
and i'll put it here
okay so this is the website of the coin
market cap
so it's displaying the price of the
various cryptocurrency
the first top hundred and so this is
essentially what we are going to web
scrape
today the top hundred price here
so we're gonna get the data of the the
name
of the cryptocurrency the symbol
bitcoin the name of it right and then
the
symbol of it is btc the price
the 24 hour price change the seven day
price change
and also the one hour price change the
market cap value
and also the volume so we're gonna web
script that today here
and all of the data will be placed
inside the df
variable
okay lines number 99 and
and 100 let's have a look here
line number 99 and 100 will be multi
selection
of the web app okay it's right here
so line number 99 and 100 will give us
this
multiple selection box here
so the top 100 will be shown here and so
you could select which cryptocurrency
you want to be shown here
let's say we delete everything and then
we're selecting btc
eth right what else
bnb right
and so we selected only three so far and
three are shown here okay
so let's use the default one of 100
all right let's continue so
upon our selection of the coins here
102 will display only the selected coins
so if we selected five only five will be
shown
in this data frame right here
and then it will also be shown in the
bar plot as well
so line 102 will do the data filtering
line number 104
let's see number of coins to display
it's right here
display the number of coins here so it's
going to be a slider
from 1 through 100
okay one through a hundred
all right so if i have it to 55
it's going to be showing the first 55
coins
see index 54 which is the
55th line and then the bar plot will be
also 55
coins as well or cryptocurrency
all right and so let's have a look at
line number 106.
so same thing it's going to do the data
filtering of the selected coins
that you selected line number 108
percent change
time frame okay as i mentioned earlier
on you could
select the time frame that you want to
be used
so by default it's using the seven days
time frame here
for the percent change and you could
change that to like 24 hours
if you like or even one hour
so the price change that happens within
the last hour
okay and then you're gonna see which
cryptocurrency had a
gain a positive gain or a significant
loss
five percent loss and this one is about
the first one is about three percent
gain within the last hour
okay
line number 114
sidebar sorting values okay so right
here
so you're going to see that the values
are sorted from highest to
lowest gain and also
loss as well so if the sort value is yes
it's going to sort the value
if it's no then it's not sorting the
value
so you see here that the values are not
sorted
and the values are in the same order
here so the first listed coin
ranked number one is btc so it's going
to
be shown at the bottom here the second
rank eth will be shown here
usdt will be shown as the third one from
the bottom
xrp will be shown as the fourth one
so it's going to be in the same order as
this data frame here
but a bit inverted okay the first round
will be at the bottom second round will
be the second from the bottom
etc
all right 117
line number 117 price data okay so this
is the data frame right here
data dimension so it's right here it's
going to print out
that that there are 100 rows and eight
columns
here eight columns
column two data frame the f coin so this
is
df coins is the data frame here
line number one two two one two eight
it's going to be allowing us to download
the
data here as a csv file
and then lines number
133 preparing the data for the bar plot
so here are here in column three we're
going to make the bar plot
so the following lines of code or the
blocks of code here will be preparing
the data
for making the bar plot
so what it will essentially do let's
have a look
so here we're going to select some of
the columns
so the coin symbol and then we're gonna
select the price change the percent
change
of one hour 24 hour and seven days
and we're going to create a new data
frame called df change
all right and then we're going to set
the index to coin symbol
so coin symbol will be moved to the
index of that data frame
and then we're going to create some
additional
new columns here we're going to call it
positive
in front of the one hour positive
in front of the 24 hour and positive of
these seven days
and we're gonna do a conditional here
so if the percent change
that happens in the last hour if it is
positive
meaning it has a value greater than zero
we're going to assign it
to the positive column
for the given time frame of one hour and
so
for the time frame of 24 hour if the
value is greater than zero
it will be assigned a value of one for
the positive
percent change 24 hour and same thing
for the seven days period
if it has a value of greater than zero
it will be assigned a value of one
in the new column called positive
percent change
and if it has a value of one in the
positive percent change here
it means that it will have a green color
however if it has a value of less than
zero it will have a red color
okay so that will be shown in the
following
lines 144 until 168.
okay and so here you're going to see
that for
the creation of the bar plot we're going
to make use of the conditional
so we're going to have three blocks here
if else if
and else so the first
we'll check whether it is seven days
and the second block will check whether
it is 24 hours
and the third one will be one hour
so right here did we select seven days
or is it 24 hour or is it one hour
and the code is right here let me find
it for you
time period
right here percent time frame select box
okay and the option is seven days 24
hour
and one hour okay percent time frame
which is right here percent time frame
okay so it's doing a conditional check
if it's seven days
it's gonna create the seven days plot if
24 hour is selected
it will create 24 hour version so
here you see that it says seven days
here and this is the plot for the seven
days
and if i choose the 24 hour then it will
go to this second block here
and it will create the 24 hour as you
see here
bar plot and if i selected the one hour
and it will go to the third block here
and here you notice that it creates the
one hour bark plot
okay and there you have it
a cryptocurrency price web application
okay so a couple of days ago i released
a video on how you can develop a simple
web application
in python using the streamlit library
and so in this video we're going to
incorporate an additional feature
which is machine learning capability
into the web application
and so without further ado let's get
started so the web application that
we're going to build today
is called the simple iris flower
prediction app and so the app will do as
it says it will predict the iris flower
type
given the four input parameters okay so
let's have a look what does the web
application looks like
so the first thing that you want to do
is head over to your command prompt so
if you're on a windows you want to click
on the search icon
type in cmd if you have a mac or a linux
you want to open up your terminal and
because i have
everything in my environment i will
activate it
by conda activate dp
then move to the desktop and then i'm
going to run the web server by typing in
streamlit
run and then the name of the file enter
and so the file to this web application
will be included in the video
description
so you want to check that out in order
to follow along with this tutorial so
notice here that it's going to spawn up
a
website for you on your local computer
and so the url here is localhost
colon and then followed by the port
number which is 8501 on my computer okay
so this is the web
application and the first line here is
the
header of the web app let's have a look
what does this
looks like let me expand it a bit okay
so as you can see here the web
application is comprised of two
components the first component is the
main panel here
shown to the right and the second
component is shown to the left
which is the sidebar panel and so the
sidebar panel here as it is called here
user input parameters it will accept the
input parameters
comprising of the four features that we
will be using
to make the prediction and under the
hood the prediction will be made
using the random forest classifier and
to the right here
upon selecting your user input values
for the four parameters here and so you
will see that the default values are
provided in the slider bar here so
we can see that simple link has a
default of 5.4
and if we modify the number here to the
right in the table we're gonna see that
number also modifies and updates as well
same thing if i modify the other
variables
you will see that the numbers inside the
table here will be
updated and correspondingly the
prediction probability and the
prediction will also be updated as well
and so the model will be applied to make
the prediction based on your input
parameters
so if you change the input parameters
the model will be used to
make the prediction once again as shown
here if i modify it then the predictions
will be created
okay pretty neat and so let's have a
look at the corresponding code which
makes all of this possible so let's head
over back to the code
and so let me give you a line by line
breakdown of the functionality of the
code here
okay so i noticed that we didn't use
numpy so we're going to delete that
okay so now it's well under 50 lines of
code
49 now all right now it's 49.
so in the first four line we're going to
import the library that we're going to
use
in this app and lines number 6 through
10 will be a simple
markdown text telling us the name of the
flower so let me open it side by side
with the web application
so the header here is right here
okay and the text here this app predicts
the ios flower type is right here
and so i can make it bold
save it and it doesn't change so i have
to say always rerun
so it will be updated automatically all
right so you see that it's bold now
and so st dot sidebar dot header
on line number 12 will be the name of
the header of the sidebar panel
right here user input parameters and so
notice that if i take out the
sidebar it will move to the right
to the main panel okay so having it in
the sidebar panel
will be possible if we use the dot
sidebar
okay so let's save it and it'll move
back to the sidebar
okay and lines number 14 through 24
will be a custom function used to accept
all of the four
input parameters from the sidebar and it
will create a
pandas data frame and the input
parameters will be obtained from this
sidebar as shown
right here to the left hand side and the
text here
will represent the name shown here so
actually i could modify the name
as such i can make it capital
and then add a space and save it and
notice that the name also updates
so why don't i do that for the other one
as well
otherwise it might be confusing whether
it is a variable name or not so this
could be any text that you want
all right and so the name is updated
here
and so the first value here represents
the minimum value and it is 4.3
and the second number here represents
the maximum value which is 7.9
and the third value represents the
current selected value or the default
value which is 5.4
so here 4.3 7.9 and 5.4
and so if you want to change the default
value to something else like 5.8
and then it would be changed to 5.8 okay
let me change it back to 5.4
all right so here we're gonna use the
custom function that we built above user
input features
and then we're going to assign it into
the df variable and this will be on line
number 26
okay and lines number 28 and 29 will be
right here user input parameters
so you can see that in just two lines of
code we could have
the section header name and the
corresponding table below so it's just a
simple print out
of the data frame and lines number 31
will be essentially just loading in the
iris dataset
line number 32 will assign the iris.data
into the x variable
and the iris.data are essentially the
four features
comprising of the simple length simple
width pedal length pedal width and this
will be used as the x variable and it
will later be used as the input argument
and the y variable here will be using
the iris.target and so they are the
class
index number of zero one two and line
number 35
we will be creating a classifier
variable comprising of the random forest
classifier and line number 36
we're going to apply the classifier to
build a training model
using as input argument the x and the y
data matrices
okay and in line number 38 we'll make
the prediction 39 will give you the
prediction
probability lines number 41 and 42
will be just a simple print out of the
class label
and their corresponding index number
line number 44
45 will give you the prediction
and so the prediction here is the class
label
of being either setosa versus color or
virginica
line number 48 and 49 will give you the
prediction
probability and so the prediction
probability will tell you what is the
probability of being in one of the three
classes
so here it is predicted to be irishitosa
so what's the probability of it being a
seltosa
so the probability is a hundred percent
so if we
change the input parameters a bit
and we're gonna see that now it is still
predicted to be setosa
but the probability of being setosa is
slightly reduced to ninety percent
and there is a seven percent chance of
it being a iris diversity color and a
three percent chance of it being a
iris virginica okay and there you have
it a simple iris flower prediction app
so in the previous video i have shown
you how you can use an alternative
to the iris data set called the palmer
penguins data set and so in this video
i'm going to show you how you can
develop a web application
for the palmer penguins dataset and so
without further ado we're starting right
now
so as briefly mentioned we're going to
use this palmer penguins dataset
that is provided by this r library
called palmer penguins
so for your convenience i'm going to
provide that data set on the
github of the data professor and so make
note that this
data set that we're going to use today
was derived from this
github library and so i'm going to show
you where you could have access to the
data that i have already exported out
from the palmer penguins library package
so it's right here in the data professor
data repository
find penguins cleaned so i have already
cleaned the data set
so you could also make use of this okay
so we're gonna use this in this tutorial
okay so let's head to the working
directory
so i'm gonna provide you the links to
all of these
code files that we're gonna use in this
tutorial okay so before we begin let's
have a quick recap and so in the first
part of this tutorial series
on streamlid i have shown you how you
could use data directly from the
wi-finance library and how we could
display a simple line chart
in part two i have shown you how you
could build a simple classification
prediction web app
for the iris data set and in this part
three we're going to use the palmer
penguins data set in order to make a
classification
web application so let's have a look at
this data set
okay so it has already been cleaned and
here there are a total of
so here there are a total of seven
columns so we have species
island bill length build up flipper link
body mass
and sex and let's scroll down
and so there are a total of three three
four
rolls so not including the first row
which is the heading there are a total
of three three three
and so we could see that we have already
deleted some of the missing values
and so it should be noted that the
missing values were deleted totally
so that is the simplest approach that
i'm using and you could feel free to
do some imputation of the data set in
order to retain
more of the data so the missing value
that were deleted could be less than
10. and so please feel free to provide
the link to your github page
where you have applied some unique
imputation approach and perhaps i could
also include it in the github of the
data professor as well so all of you
guys
all of us can have access to your
imputed and cleaned data set
and so in the meantime we're going to
use this data set that i have already
cleaned and it is called penguins
underscore cleaned.csv and so in part
two where we built a simple iris
classification
web application you might notice that
the code is building the prediction
model every time that we load the file
in
and every time that we make adjustment
to the input features
it's going to rebuild the model over and
over and so as some of you have pointed
out
this particular flaw of the code i
totally agree with you and so the
previous version was built like that for
the simplicity of the tutorial and so in
this tutorial we're going to use
another approach where we could
beforehand build a prediction model
pick all the object which is to save it
into a file and then within the
streamlit code we're going to read in
the saved file and so the advantage of
that is that there is no need to rebuild
the model every time that the input
parameters
are changed and so let's have a look at
that
okay so the code that we're using is
called penguinsmodelbuilding.py
and let's take a look at the code let's
edit with adam
all right so here so we're going to use
pandas spd
and then we're going to read in the csv
of the penguinsclean.csv here which is
also provided in the same directory
as you can see here and then we're going
to
take this penguin's data frame take the
data and put it into the df
variable and then we're going to define
the target and the encode variable
according to the
excellent kernel kaggle provided in this
link
from pratik and so kudos to pratik for
the code that we're using as the basis
of this tutorial
and so here we're going to use ordinal
feature encoding in order to
encode the qualitative features such as
species
island and sex and so the objective of
this tutorial we're going to predict the
species of the penguin and so if you
would like to predict the sex of the
penguin you could replace species with
sex
and then you could put species in here
okay so actually this was the exact
parameters used by protic in his
kaggle kernel but in this tutorial i
have modified it a bit
by using the species as the target where
we're going to predict the species of
the penguin
and the sex and island will be used as
the input parameters
okay so this block of code here will be
encoding the
sex and island columns and in this block
of code here it's going to encode the
target species and in this line of code
here we're going to apply this
custom function in order to perform the
encoding
and so in this two lines of code we're
going to separate the data set into x
and y data matrices in order to use it
for model building and scikit-learn
right because here x will be the input
features
and y will be the species so in x we
have six
features and in y we have one feature
and so here we're going to build a
random forest model and
from sklearn.ensemble we're going to
import random forest classifier and
we're going to assign the random force
classifier to the clf
variable and then we're going to use the
fit function in order to build the model
using
x and y as the import argument and then
finally here we're going to save the
model using the pickle library and we're
going to use the pickle.dump function
and as input argument we're going to use
the clf
which is the model that we have already
built and then we're going to open
or we're going to create a file called
penguins underscore
clf dot pkl
okay so let's close the file and run
this
code so we could do this right inside
the command line
so i'm opening up the command prompt
heading over to desktop
going into the streamlet folder going
into the penguins
folder and then i'm going to activate my
environment
and then we're going to run the code
in model building
python
so i have to make sure to type in
penguins dash
and then the tab function okay there you
have it all right so
as you can see the file popped up here
and the pickled file has been created
successfully
all right so we're going to copy this to
the
previous folder in here
okay so let's have a look at the
penguins app here
okay so the first five lines we're going
to import the necessary
libraries so here we're going to import
srimlet sst
import pandas spd import numpy snp
import pickle and from sklearn.ensemble
import random forest classifier
okay and in this block of code here is
the
title in markdown format and the
corresponding description of this web
application
so why don't we have a look side by side
so let's resize the window a bit
cd desktop cd streamlet
conda activate dp
penguins
okay streamlit run
penguins dash app
in order to run the application
so it's popping up the window here
okay so this is the finished application
that we're gonna build today
and as you can see if we change the
input parameters the prediction here
will be changed
automatically so we could see
right and we're also going to get the
corresponding prediction probability as
well
and so it should be noted here that this
web application was much more difficult
than using the iris data set partly
because
of the issue with the two qualitative
features that we're
using so the thing is with iris data set
if we're using that
it's going to contain only the
quantitative features so there won't be
any ordinal features like sex
or island and so under the hood we have
to encode the ordinal features
and for example for the island feature
here
we're going to create three additional
columns called island bisco
island dream island torgersen and for
each
of this three feature we're going to
have binary value one or zero it has the
island being visco if the island bisco
is having a value of one and so if the
island biscuit has a value of one
for a particular penguin then it will
also have corresponding value of zero
for dream and corresponding value of
zero for
torgersen and so the same thing for sex
we're going to create two additional
features sex
male sex female and for input feature
here if the sex is male then the sex
male feature will have a value of one
and the sex
female will have a value of zero so
therefore we will create
five additional features on top of the
four features that we have that are
quantitative so that will bring us to a
total of nine
features so that was a bit complicated
but we have already solved the issue for
you guys
and the code is inside here so let's
have a look
so here we're using st.sidebar dot
header
user input feature and so that is the
name of this sidebar
heading and then we have st.sidebar
markdown and so we're going to provide
example of the csv file and the link
to the csv file that is an example is
called
penguins example and so you can see that
we're providing the link to this
csv file in markdown format
and so you could click on it and it will
bring you to this data set
so in order to download this you would
have to right click and then save link
as
in order to do that so the reason for
having the example csv input file here
is because i have been receiving some
comments whether i could include a
feature where the user could upload
their
input file and so in this tutorial i'm
going to show you that
okay so here we're going to download the
csv file
and notice that it's providing the
extension.txt
and we have to make it csv save it
all right so this is the input features
that we're going to use
and we're going to upload the file
and there you go the uploaded file are
used as the input features here
and a prediction is being made here okay
so it predicts this input as
a delhi and with corresponding
prediction probability okay so as you
can see there are two possibilities for
the input features so the first option
is to import the file as csv format and
the second possibility is to directly
input the parameters by the slider bar
and so under the hood the code will be
using one or the other as the input
for the predictions to be made and so
for doing that we're going to use the if
else
conditional so let's have a look further
so in line number 22 here it is using
the
st.sidebar file uploader and so
it will give us this functionality to
allow us to upload files
and so the uploaded file will go into
the variable called uploaded file
and so we're going to make use of
conditionals here and so there will be
two scenarios we're gonna use
if there is an uploaded file and the
uploaded file
is not empty not none meaning that if
the uploaded file is not
empty then we should create a input df
variable and then we're going to read in
the uploaded file or in else
then we're going to run this block of
code here and so the block of code here
will essentially define a function
that will accept the input parameters
from the
slide bar here okay so as you can see
the conditional
have two possibilities if there is an
uploaded file
create a data frame and read in the
uploaded file else
read in the input parameters directly
from the slider bar
okay and so notice that the contents of
the input will be
saved into the same input df variable
so that will be easy for the following
blocks of code
so previously i've shown you now how you
can import the library
write the header of the web app shown
here and along with the description
and then the header of the sidebar
along with the link to the example csv
file here and then the
upload functionality shown here and then
in this block of conditional if else
regarding the input features
if there is a file to be uploaded or if
not then we're going to use the slider
bar as the input
okay so now the fun part comes in
reading in
the data from the penguins underscore
clean dot csv and then we're going to
drop the
species column because we're going to
predict that
column and therefore we're going to drop
it here and now we're going to combine
the input underscore df to the entire
data set of penguins
and so the encoding code that we're
using it is expecting that there are
multiple values
inside the particular column that it
wants to encode so for example in the
island
variable it is expecting that there are
three possibilities
right the three different island or in
the sex column it is expecting that
there are two
male female okay and so the thing is the
input feature that we're using here will
be from
one penguin sample and so let's say that
one penguin sample could have island as
biscuo and therefore it will only know
of one possibility
and so this block of code will not work
so therefore we have to integrate this
input features on top of the existing
penguin dataset
so before we might have 333 rows then
it's three three three
plus one so that makes it three three
four and then we're going to perform the
encoding
and then there will be two possibilities
for sex three possibility for island
okay all right so now we're going to
display the user input in the user input
features
so right here user input feature is this
block of code
and we're going to use conditional again
and so the first possibility is
if there is an uploaded file write out
the content
otherwise write out the content of the
slider bar
and then also put the text that we are
awaiting the csv file to be uploaded
so in this scenario it's telling us that
there is no input file uploaded and if
we upload the input file
then this line of code will be
disappearing okay so let's proceed
further
and so this is the classification model
part so in the previous
part two of the streamlight tutorial on
iris dataset we've built the random
forest model right inside the streamlit
application but in this tutorial we're
just reading in
the saved file which i have shown you at
the beginning of this video
so the pickled object is called penguin
clf
dot pkl so we're going to read that in
and we're going to assign it the load
clf
variable and then here on line 71 we're
going to create a prediction variable
and then we're going to assign
the value of the predicted value and so
we're using
load underscore clf dot predict function
and then input argument is df and df
is corresponding to the input features
either from the
uploaded file or from the sidebar okay
and so that is df and then on line 72
we're also going to use
df as the input argument to the predict
prabha
function and that will provide you the
prediction probability
okay and so in the block of code of line
75
through 77 it's going to write out the
predicted value of the
penguin and so here it is predicted to
be gen 2 and then on line
79 and 80 it's going to predict the
probability
okay and so the probability values are
shown in this data frame here and so
here we can see that
it is predicted to be gen 2 and there is
a prediction probability of 81
so this can be taken as the relative
confidence that we have
in this prediction so it's kind of like
we're 81 confident that this prediction
is correct
however for other prediction the
probability could be decreased to 67. so
as you can see when we reduce the body
mass
the probability decreased but if we
increase the
body mass the probability increased
three two one okay so welcome back to
the data professor
youtube channel my name is chanin ahmad
and i'm an associate professor of
bioinformatics
and in this video i'm going to talk
about how you can develop a web
application
powered by machine learning for the
boston housing data set so without
further ado
we're starting right now okay so today
we're going to create a simple web
application
that is powered by machine learning and
we're going to use the boston housing
data set
as our example so in your data science
learning journey you probably have came
across the
boston housing data set so let's take a
quick look
so the boston housing data set is
comprised of 506
rows 14 columns
so the 14 columns are provided here so
these are the descriptions of the 14
columns
and the target response that we're going
to predict is
called the median value of owner
occupied homes
in 1 000 units so if you would like
some more details read these
resources and so let's dive into the
code
okay so let me open up my adam text
editor
all right so let's have a look at the
code
so the code is 86
lines so i provided you some bonuses
here
so aside from making the prediction
we're also going to provide you
the understanding behind the prediction
okay so these will be in about 10 lines
of code
and it's using the shaft library so
actually
the entire code for the web application
for predicting the
house price is 71 lines of code
so actually we could make it fewer lines
of code if we
just deleted the extra spacing that i
have made here so like for example if i
just do it like this
then i would save a lot of spaces
but i'm going to use excessive lines
in order to make the code look as simple
as possible
okay so let's get started so the first
six
lines of code as we see here are for
importing the various libraries
so the first line is we're gonna import
streamlit as
st line number two we're going to import
pandas
as pd so line number three we're going
to import the shaft
library and the shape library will
provide you the understanding
behind the prediction number four we're
going to import matplotlib.pyplot as
plt line number five we're going to
import
the dataset from sklearn in line number
six we're going to import the random
forest
regressor from sklearn.ensemble
okay so let me run this web application
so that you could see it side by side
with the code
so let me click on the search and then
type in cmd
i'm going to go into my environment
for running data science so i'm going to
activate
my environment called dp so for those of
you
you don't have dp as your environment so
you can
create your own environment and then
when you have already created that
you will activate it using conda
activate dp
okay so i might probably make a future
video about how you can create
environments in conda so maybe a brief
teaser so the reason for
using environment is that we don't want
to mess up our computer
so for example if we installed libraries
that might
influence the version number of other
dependency
library so that might ruin your other
data science project
so for example if you're using pandas
1.0 in one project
and then in the other project you
require panda 0.93
and so there will be incompatibility
issues right so
it's working for one version but then
when you install
another library which is depending on
0.93
then it's not going to work when you
have pandas 1.0 so in order to counter
that
it would be best to run a different data
science project
in a different environment okay so
different meaning that
not every single project that you're
running you have to create a new
environment but
you're going to create a new environment
if you're using
different libraries okay so like for
example here in this tutorial
i'm using predominantly sklearn and
streamlit so whenever i do tutorials
about sklearn and streamlit i would use
this
particular environment okay
so let's continue so i have already
activated the environment
and i'm going to move into the desktop
here
and then i'm going to run the code
streamlit run and then the code name is
boston house
all right so i just type in the first
field character hit on the tab
and then it's going to auto fail for you
hit on enter
and then we're going to load up the
local version
all right so this is the web application
that we're developing
okay so i'm not sure why feature
important is not shown here
try loading it again
it's running all right feature
importance is loaded
so this is the web app let's have it
side by side
all right here so lines number eight
through 13
right here is going to be corresponding
to the title of the web page
which is right here so line number nine
we're using the hashtag which
is a equivalence to the h1 heading in
html
and it is called boston house price
prediction app
and then in the normal text we're going
to type in this app predicts the boston
house price
and then in markdown language we're
using two asterisk
which is equivalent to bolding the text
okay
if i make it only one asterisk it will
be
in italic
see it'll be in italy okay so i'm just
undoing it that
all right and then in lines number 16
we're going to import the boston house
data set
and then we're going to split that into
x and y
data frames so the x data frame will
contain only the
independent variables or the x variables
so sometimes you call these as the input
features
and then in the y variable here we're
going to have the target
and the target here is the median value
of the house price
all right and on line number 22
until line number 52
it is the side panel right here
so line number 22 it is the header of
the side panel
specify input parameters so lines number
24 until 52 we're defining a custom
function
for accepting user input features
so here we see that we have the 13
features
and then the 13 features will accept
input here so we're going to make use of
the
st.sidebar dot slider and then as the
input argument we're going to have the
name of the
feature crim and then the next is the
minimum value
the maximum value and the mean value
so why do we need to add these values
here minimum maximum and the mean
so the minimum value here is the value
that you're going to see here at the
lower limit of the slider and then the
max value will be at the upper limit of
the slider
and the mean value will be the default
value that we're going to put
into the input parameters okay
so the mean value of crim is 3.61 right
but once we change this then the
prediction will be
modified so we're going to use the same
logic for the remaining
input features and then finally we're
going to put all of the features here
into a data frame
and the data frame will be returned here
and then we're going to make use of the
custom function and then we're going to
call it df we're going to assign the
default
input features here into the df data
frame
and then in lines number 59 it's going
to be corresponding to here
specified input parameters line number
60 will be printing out the
df line number 61 will be printing out
this
long horizontal line as a divider
and line number 64 until 67 we're going
to build a random forest
model we're going to train the model on
line number 65.
and then we're going to make the
prediction on line number 67.
so a point you note here is that a model
will be built every time the input
parameters
are modified so in order to improve the
code
let me make it your homework try to
create the model outside of streamlet
webapp file that you're seeing here make
a pickle file save it as dot pkl
and then you want to load that pico file
into this web app
so that you don't have to rebuild the
model every time
okay so you just built the model once
you read it in
to the web app the pkl file and then you
will apply the pkl file which is the
model
to make the prediction using the input
parameters that you specify
in the sidebar okay
so think of that as your homework and
let me know in the description
how that went all right
so line number 69 you're going to see
the header here
prediction of the median value and then
you're gonna make the
st right to print out the prediction
value which is 20.084
and then finally in the remaining 10
lines of code
we're going to print out the plots
provided by the shaft
library so line number 75 and 76
it's going to extract the shop values
line number 78 is going to print out the
header here
feature importance line number 79 is
going to
print the header of the plot i mean the
title of the plot
line number 80 is going to make a
feature importance plot
and then finally we're going to see the
typical feature importance plot
that we normally see when we're using
random forest
so here you're not going to see how it
is contributing
to the overall prediction for example
you're going to see that else that is
important
rm is important but then you're not
going to see important in what aspect
are they contributing positively
or negatively to the predicted values so
in the
shop plot here you're going to see that
l-stat
is contributing relatively equal on the
negative aspect
and the positive aspect but for the
feature importance plot
using the shaft value you're going to
see the relative distribution
on whether it contributed to the
negative or the positive
side of the feature importance okay so
something handy
and useful to see
in this video i'm going to show you how
you can build a bioinformatics
web application and without further ado
we're starting right now
so in prior episodes i have shown you
how you could use the streamlet
library in python to build simple web
application
ranging from a simple financial web
application where you could check the
stock price a simple web application
where you could predict the
boston housing price a penguin species
prediction
web application and so in today's
episode we're going to talk about how
you could build a
simple bioinformatics web application
and it's going to be based on the prior
tutorial
videos that are mentioned in this
channel so the bioinformatics web
application that we're going to be
building today
will be an extension of a tutorial
series where i have shown you how you
could build a
molecular solubility prediction model
using machine learning
where particularly we are applying
machine learning and python
to the field of computational drug
discovery and if you think of it in the
grand scheme of things it is part of the
bioinformatics
research area and so this video will
focus more on the aspect of actually
building the web application
and if you're interested in how to build
the prediction model
on the molecular solubility that we will
be using today
let me refer you to the prior tutorial
videos on this channel
and the links will be provided in the
video description
and also the pen comments of this video
okay and so let's get started shall we
so we're going to go to the streamlet
directory
and then it's going to be located in the
solubility folder and so all of these
are the actual files that we're going to
be using today
and so actually i think i have the
prediction model
on google colab
let me download that
okay it's right here and so this will be
a concise version
of the contents of a prior video where i
have shown you how you could build
machine learning models of the molecular
solubility data set
and so as i mentioned already i will
provide the links to this video
and so let's connect to this and let's
have a look
so let me clear all of the outputs
and then it's already connected and so
we're going to import pandas as
pd we're going to be
downloading the calculated descriptors
directly from the github of the data
professor
and so this has already been computed as
mentioned in the prior video
and so these are the computed
descriptors molag p
mol weight number of rotatable bonds
aromatic proportion
so these four are the computed
descriptor from the prior video
that i have mentioned and the log s is
the y
variable that we will be computing or
predicting
so these four variables are the x
variables
okay and so we're going to separate this
data frame into
two sets of variables one is the x
variable
so we'll be dropping the log s column
and then we're going to have the last
column
as the index number is indicating here
minus one which is lock s
okay so the x variables will be
containing all of the
columns except for log s and the y
variable will be containing
only the log s okay and so we're going
to be building the linear regression
model here
and so we're going to import the linear
model from sklearn
and we're going to also compute the
performance
metric by importing mean squared error
and the r2 score function from the
sklearn.metric
so let's run that and then we're going
to run the linear regression
and then we're going to assign this to
model and then we're going to
perform the model.fit using the x
variables
in order to predict the y and so we will
be
building a training model here x not
defined okay so i haven't yet run this
so let me do that first all right so
let's
do the model building okay so the model
has
already been built and then we're going
to be performing the prediction
all right prediction has been made and
it is assigned to the
y pred variable and the prediction is
made
using the model dot predict and then
using
x as the input argument and then we're
going to print the
model performance here and these four
values are the regression coefficient
values for each of the four input
variables
of the x compressing of molar p
molecular weights
number of rotatable bonds aromatic
proportion
so the regression coefficient will
represent the magnitude that
each of these four variables are
contributing to the prediction
of the y so the greater the magnitude
the greater the influence of that
particular
variable and so the y-intercept is right
here the mean squared error
1.01 the r-squared value 6.77
and then let's print out the model
equation okay so this is the equation
and then we're going to visualize the
scatter plot
of the actual versus the predicted
okay so let's run the scatter plot here
all right so this is the experimental
versus the predicted log
s value so as we have seen here from the
r
squared we're getting pretty good
correlation between the
experimental and the predicted lock s
values
and finally we're going to pick up the
object here
so essentially we're going to save the
model into a file called
solubilitymodel.pkl
and so we're going to import this into
the streamlit web application
and so we have already run it and then
we could simply
click on this corner here and then click
on the download
file okay and it's essentially the same
thing that we have right here
but it should be noted that the version
of scikit-learn
on google colab and on the local version
that i have installed will be different
and it will be giving some warning
values
so it might be worthwhile to copy all of
the code here
into a file and then run it locally so
that it's going to be using the same
version of the
scikit-learn okay so let's think of that
as a homework for you guys
and let's get started in building our
web application now
so let's head over to the streamlight
folder installability
and let's have a look at the contents
here so the delani solubility here
so these are the input descriptors
comprising of the x and y variables that
we have been using
just a moment ago to build the
prediction model so i'm going to provide
you these
files in the github that is dedicated to
this tutorial
and also the jupiter notebook that we
have seen just a moment ago
for building the prediction model of
this solubility data set
and so that jupiter notebook will be
using
this input file here but also in the
code
it is downloading directly from the
github of the data professor
so actually we don't actually need this
as well so
i can just delete that and then i'm just
gonna provide you the
juvenile notebook and
okay so a total of three files will be
used for this web application
so the first one is the logo
so this is the logo that we will be
using for the
web application so i have drawn this in
the ipad
using the good notes application so here
it is called molecular
solubility prediction app so given input
molecule
the machine learning model will be
predicting the lock
s value
okay so let's fire up the atom
editor let's have a look at the contents
of solubility app dot py
okay so let's see so there's a total of
about 110
lines of code and so notice that i have
also included
several lines of code that are
essentially the comments here
and so these are just for ease of
reading
having a look at what each block of
codes are doing
all right so if deleting the comments
it will be probably just under a hundred
lines of code
so let's take a look at the code here
okay so
the first block of code that we will be
using are
essentially importing libraries that are
needed here
and so we'll be importing the numpy
and so numpy will be used for the
descriptor calculation
we'll be using pandas because we need to
read in the data set
and actually we will be using it to
prepare the data frames
as well in the generate code here
the function that we use for computing
the molecular descriptors
so full detail as i have mentioned will
be provided in a prior
video that i have shown you in a
step-by-step manner
and the hero of this tutorial is the
streamlet library
so this is the basis of this web
application
and we'll be importing pickle in order
to allow
us to save the machine learning model
and then importing it in to this web
application
and then we're going to be using the
image function
from pil in order to display the logo
that i have shown you just a moment ago
and here we'll be using the chem
and descriptors function of the rd kits
it would be for computing the molecular
descriptors
and the molecular descriptors are
essentially allowing us
to describe molecules in terms of their
physical chemical properties and so for
ease of usage we have already created
the custom function
for calculating the molecular
descriptors and they are provided here
from lines here 12 which are the
comments until lines 57
and so we will be having two custom
function aromatic proportion
and the generate function and let's take
a look at the web application so let me
run the web application right now
conda activate dp you don't need to do
this
if you have already installed all of the
libraries up for your python
directly in the command line but if you
use conda
then you want to activate the
environment that is
dedicated for running your data science
projects
so i highly recommend installing conda
and then
creating a specialized environment for
your data science projects
so that will help us to maintain the
library dependencies
otherwise if you have several projects
on your computer
and then when you upgrade one library it
might
downgrade other libraries or other
dependencies
as a result and then it might make some
of your prior data science project
not workable so i highly recommend to
use
conda and specialized environment for
managing your
data science project okay so we have
already activated dp here
and we're going to go to the directory
streamlit installability
okay so we have three files here and
we're going to run it
streamlit run solubility
app.py
okay and now this is the web application
okay so the left hand side here is the
input parameters
which is the smiles input will represent
the
chemical information of the input
molecule so each
line represents a different molecule so
we have three lines here
as an example and you could replace this
with your own data
and then we will be able to predict the
value of the
solubility as a function of the input
smiles notation here so let me repeat
this again
this portion the smiles notation here
each line represents a single molecule
so you're seeing here three lines so it
represents three
molecules and each smile citation will
tell us what is the atomic composition
of the molecule and so here we see that
the first line of code here
cccc it has five carbon atoms and the
second one has
three carbon atoms and third one is a
carbon atom and a nitrogen atom
okay and we can even search for smiles
of a molecule of our interest and let's
search for a molecule of our interest
let's search for aspirin and
let's click on it
and let's find smiles i'm going to
search for it command
f and then search for smiles and
we have it here in 2.1.4
canonical smiles so we're going to copy
that
so this is the smiles notation and so
i'm going to copy and then i'm going to
paste it here
and then after we paste it here we have
to press command
and enter in order to apply this
and then note that the predicted value
here will be updated so let's try it
command
enter because i'm on a mac so i have to
do command enter
and so on windows is probably ctrl enter
and so here we have the input smiles
notation
which is right here the same thing on
the left and then
below here we have the computed
molecular descriptors which are the
four physical chemical properties here
comprising of the
moloch p molecular weight number of
rotatable bonds
aromatic proportion so these four
variables are computed using the rd
kids library let me go back here rd kit
right here
rd kit rd kit okay so using the chem
and descriptors function and using the
custom function that we have written
to compute the aromatic proportion which
is right here
aromatic proportion and also the
mole log p which is the first column
here
molecular weight which is the second
column here
number of rotatable bonds which is right
here
and the aromatic proportion
is a custom function because rd kit does
not
compute that property and so we will
have to create our own
function in order to compute the
aromatic proportion
and so why did we use these four
variables here
how did we know that we have to compute
these four descriptors
it's because the original work by john
dilani he used these four variables for
building his prediction model so if you
would like for more
information please have a look at this
original research paper
and so here finally we have the
predicted log s
value and we have it predicted to be
minus 2.0931
so this is the relative solubility value
okay so there we have it a
simple web application for predicting
the molecular solubility
values so let's have a look further into
the code
so image this line of code here 63
line 63 is this image it is for
displaying the image
by essentially assigning it opening it
and then assigning it to the image
variable and then using the st.image in
order to
actually display the image and then use
column width to be true in order to
expand
image to fit the column width and then
here we're going to write
out molecular solubility prediction app
right here we can even modify this to be
like
web app save it and then
rerun it and then you're going to see
that the name is updated to be web app
and then these are the descriptors so
this is
in markdown format so markdown is
allowing us to format text to have
links italic or bold face
as well for example if we want to make
the text bold we're going to be using
double
asterisk before and after okay for
highlighting solubility lock s
we're going to add the double asterisk
before and after
if we want this to be bold and also in
italic
we need three of them click on
always rerun so you see that it is in
italic
okay and also bold and what if we have
only one italic what happens here
so a single asterisk will make it in
a italic form and if we have two it
becomes bold
okay
and if you want to add links to it then
we have the bracket here
to define the boundaries of the
text that we want to be linked and then
in parenthesis we're
going to add the link the url here
and so you can click on this and it will
take us to the original paper
okay and this is the original paper
it was published in 2004.
okay so this block of code here will be
reading in the input features which is
the smiles notation
so sc.sidebar header will be the header
here
the heading user input features and then
read
smiles input so this is the example
input that we will be using
and notice here that we use 5c
let's rerun this so five c is right here
and then notice that when we have a
backslash
n it becomes a new line and then we have
three c
which is right here and then we have a
backslash n
which is a new line and then it becomes
cn okay which is the third line here
okay ccc here ctc here
and then cn and cn
okay and this is the
input text of the smiles notation
okay so the text box that we see here
comes from this
text area function and the input
argument include the smiles input which
is the name of this
right here and then the smiles
underscore input will be
the example smiles notation that we have
used here
so if we change this we change the first
one from c to n
and then this will be changed right
it becomes n now
okay and then we're going to add a dummy
first item
here in order to allow us to simply
read in multiple lines of smiles
notation
and then later we're going to be
skipping that dummy first item
and so we're going to do the same for
multiple times
on line number 91 96 and also when we
make the prediction
so this will allow us to simply create
a data frame of the smiles notation
and also for generating the data frame
of the computed molecular descriptors
for a single input parameter so imagine
if we have only a single molecule
okay this works okay but if we don't
have the
dummy items let me show you
which is at three places lines number 87
96 110 so let's save it
so without the dummy let's see what
happens here
okay and when we try to make a
prediction
we get an error
right here unless you okay so this is
having
okay it's skipping here okay i have to
hide this one too 91 as well
so actually it is 87 91
96 and also 110.
okay let's rerun it
so this will work right
oh okay so i think we're skipping
oh yeah we cannot
okay we have to display x here otherwise
nothing will be shown
and then we have to display smiles here
otherwise nothing will be shown see
nothing is shown here
and then we need to show the prediction
so we need to type in prediction
okay so instead of slicing from the
second value onwards we're going to have
it printing
all of it okay now it should work
all right it works now so notice that it
works if it has
multiple lines for the smiles notation
here but what if it
has only one okay
only one command enter
and now we have an error here okay
so for ease of handling a single
input parameters we're going to use the
dummy item
as i have mentioned
right here we're going to be reading the
second value onwards
okay now it works right we have a single
value here and we make a prediction it
works
okay all right let's continue
so i have already mentioned that we have
the input
smiles notation here and the computed
molecular descriptors
is provided here in this block of code
so very simple here
so all of the hard work is done here in
the custom function
and so we're going to be using only the
generate because generate will be using
the aromatic proportion right here
aromatic proportion function
and then we're going to be using the
generate function right here line number
95
and then the input argument will be the
smiles and the smiles here will be what
it will be
the input smiles that we have okay so
these will be the input right
so it will be split according to the
backslash n
so each line of code here each line of
the
smiles notation will represent a unique
molecule
okay and then each molecule will be
computed for its molecular descriptors
and then it will be shown here in the x
variable so if we recall y equal to f
of x therefore x will be the input
parameters
for predicting the y value which is the
log
s okay and so the model has already been
pre-built
in the google colab just a moment ago
and we are loading in the model here
using the pickle.load function
and the solubilitymodel.pkl
and then we're going to make use of this
loaded model here
loadmodel.predict and then using
the input x which we have already
computed here right here right so
there's three major components
so the input smiles here
is here these are the example right
but if we change this to something else
like aspirin right then this whole thing
theoretically will be here
we'll be here okay we'll be like that
okay
and then it will enter here and then it
will be
subjected to descriptor calculation
using the generate function and then
finally we have the x variables and then
the x variable here
will be used as the input argument
when we want to make a prediction okay
and so finally here
we're going to be using the computed
molecular descriptors that are contained
within the x variables and then we're
going to use the
loaded model that we have already
predicted which we have already built
on the google code lab and then we save
it out using the pickle object and then
we're loading it back in
into the streamlit web application and
then we're going to be applying this
built model here load model dot predict
and then the input argument will be x
which are the computed molecular
descriptors
and finally here st dot header is
corresponding to
right here predicted lock as values and
then the actual prediction will be shown
right here prediction and it's going to
be showing right here okay
so we can have multiple lines let's say
that we have
multiple on input files so here let's
say that we have multiple
molecules let's change this to something
else so
we're going to get a different molecule
and so we're going to see that the
prediction value also changes right if
we want to
change a carbon to the nitrogen what
will happen here right
so the log s value changes here and so
you're going to see that
it influences the molecular weight and
also the molar p
but not the number of rotatable bonds
and the aromatic proportion
so changing a carbon to a nitrogen is
essentially changing one atom
and so it will be influencing two
descriptors here
all right so congratulations you have
now built a very simple bioinformatics
web application
particularly for drug discovery
have you been using streamlit library in
creating some web applications
perhaps you have already successfully
deployed the web application
locally but do you want to deploy it
onto the internet so that other people
could have access to your
awesome web application if you answered
yes then you want to watch this video to
the end because i'm going to show you
how you could deploy the
streamlet web application onto the
internet using hiroku so without further
ado
we're starting right now okay so the
first thing that you want to do
is head over to the github of the data
professor
and you want to go to the repository
called penguins heroku
so all of the files that we will be
using to deploy onto hiroku will be
provided in this
repository so the web application that
we are going to deploy
is the penguins classification web app
that we have previously created
in the third part of this streamlit
tutorial okay so let's have a look at
this repository so
we're gonna see that it comprises of
this initiating
readme so this will provide us with the
details that we see on the github
and other than that we have copied the
following four files from the
github of the penguins web application
penguinsapp.py
penguinsclean.csv penguinclf.pkl
penguinsexample.csv so these four files
were copied directly from the repository
that i'm going to show you right now so
we're going to code
we're going to streamlit and it was from
part 3. so we copied everything except
for the
modelbuilding.py because the
modelbuilding.py
will produce the pkl and that's what we
need which is the
saved model that we have created let's
head back
all right and aside from the four files
which is directly related to the
streamlade web application
we're also going to create three
additional files
called the proc file requirements.txt
setup.sh so let's have a look at the
proc file
so the proc file will essentially run
the setup.sh
file and run the streamlet web
application
the requirements.txt will tell heroku to
install the following python library and
the corresponding version
and so i'm going to show you in just a
moment how i came up with this
precise version number
and we also created this setup.sh so
this will handle issues regarding the
server side in terms of the port number
and it will add it to the configuration
okay so let's have a look at the
requirements.txt so what did i do
let us open up the command prompt so i
typed in
cmd in the search and i'm going to
activate my
conda environment so if you have a
contact environment you want to activate
that using the name of your conda
environment
and so the conduct environment on my
computer is called dp
so i'm going to activate that
so let me type conda list
and we're going to see the exact version
number that we have
installed on our computer so let's see
what do we have
we have streamlit so
we have right here streamlit version
okay so i've been using different
computer so actually on
this computer that i'm using to record
this youtube video
i'm using a lenovo desktop which is
running on a windows
and the number that you see here is from
my macbook pro so they're using slightly
different number here
and so pandas on this windows notebook
is 1.0.1 whereas i have the older
version on my macbook pro
and numpy 1.18.1 numpy 1.18.1
scikit-learn 0.22.1
let's have a look scikit-learn 0.2.1
okay so the important thing is if you
have already tested that your web
application works on your current
computer
and you want to copy the exact version
number into your requirements.txt
so at the time of testing i used my
macbook pro
and so these were the version numbers
from the macbook pro
and so this worked perfectly so nothing
wrong with this so what you could do in
this
requirements.txt file is to include all
of the
library that you are using in your code
so why did i
include these for library let's have a
look at the code it's because
in the penguinsapp.py we've been using
the
streamlit library the pandas library
numpy
and because pickle is built in we don't
need to include that
and also the scikit-learn so there's a
total of four
streamlid one pandas numpy and
scikit-learn
okay and then i included the exact
version number
and make a note that you need to have
two
equal sign here okay and so we have a
total of
seven files and including the readme
that we have eight files
and as a recall the four files here
beginning with the penguins
are related to the web application that
we have created in srimlet and the three
files comprising of proc file
requirements.txt setup.sh
will tell hiroku what to do what library
to install
which version to use and what precise
command to run in order to run the
streamlet web application okay so let's
head over to heroku now
so if you haven't yet signed up for
hiroku you want to sign up and
if you have already signed up you want
to log in
okay so after logging in we will see
this
dashboard and so these are the web
application that i have already created
in hiroku and so
if we want to create a new app what we
need to do is click on new
and then click on create new app
and then you want to give the name of
your app here so let me try
penguins
okay that doesn't work app
how about penguins st st for
streamlit or even just penguin streamlit
okay so that works and then once you're
satisfied with the name of your app and
make sure that it is available
otherwise it will give you a error like
this
in red it's not available and then
you just find a name that's available
okay penguin streamlit and you could
also select the region
of the server that is going to host your
web application so the options here are
united states
and europe so we're going to select the
united states
and then you want to hit on the create
app
wait a few moment all right so in the
deployment method you want to click on
github
okay so i have already connected my
github account with hiroku so if you
haven't yet done that then you want to
also do that as well and after you have
already connected your github account
with heroku
then you could type in the name of your
repository
so what was the name of the repository
it is called penguins heroku
so let's copy that penguins heroku
and then click on search click on
connect
and here you could also enable the
option
for automatic deploy meaning that
whenever there is a change
in your web application files on the
github it will automatically deploy your
web application
onto hiroku so i'm just gonna leave that
out
and we're just gonna proceed with the
manual deploy
so don't do anything here so the default
is master
and then you want to click on the deploy
branch
okay scroll down and then you want to
have a look at this
feed here so it's going to provide you
with the output in real time
so what it is currently doing is
installing the necessary python library
so the good thing about hiroku is that
you don't have to worry about the
server you don't have to maintain the
server so the only thing that you need
to care about is the
application itself so the thing is you
just upload your
application onto github and then you
connect that with hiroku
and then you could just simply deploy
that web application
so here it is also installing
dependencies as well
so this might take a couple of minutes
so
in the meantime you might want to grab a
cup of coffee and sit back
relax and enjoy
okay so it is finished so it's going to
be deployed at
penguins dash streamlit.heroku app.com
wait a couple of seconds and it's going
to create the link
at the bottom yeah right here so
whenever it is finished
you will see the link at the bottom it
will say your app was successfully
deployed and then you could simply click
on the
view link here and this will bring you
the web
all right so it's apparently loading and
when that web application is loading for
the first time
it might take you some time okay so now
the web application is loaded and so
let's play around with the input
parameters and as we can see the
prediction
label changes along with the prediction
probability
okay so congratulations you have now
successfully deployed your streamlit
web application onto heroku
do you want to deploy your web
application that you have just created
in python using the streamlet library
if you answered yes then this video is
for you because
today i'm going to show you how you
could easily deploy your web application
onto streamlit and without further ado
we're starting right now
okay so the first thing that you want to
do is head over to the github of the
data professor
and then you want to click on the
repositories
and then click on streamlit10
and so a streamline10 will essentially
be the 10th episode
of the streamlet series on this youtube
channel and
so here we're using the sp 500-app.py
so i'll provide you the links of the
10th episode in the description of this
video
and so we're gonna use this to deploy
the app
in this tutorial so let's have a look at
that
okay so this is the app contents
so in a nutshell it will essentially web
scrape the data directly from wikipedia
of the s p 500 and then
it's going to download the y finance
data set directly from the yahoo finance
via the y finance library and then it
will
create a data frame of the data and then
it will also allow us to download the
data as a csv file and
finally we're also able to make some
beautiful plots here all right and so
we're gonna
proceed with deploying the app and so
before continuing further
it should be noted that we need also the
requirements.tx file which will list
all of the dependency meaning the
libraries that we're
using in our web app and also the
corresponding version number
so how do i get this let me show you
so you can get this by going to your
terminal and i have already
logged into my conda environment so i
will directly type
pip freeze and then
requirements dot txt
and then let's have a look at the
contents of the file
and notice that i have all of the
libraries that are installed in my conda
environment
along with the corresponding version
number so i will
selectively choose the libraries that
are
used for the web app and then i'm going
to copy the corresponding lines
like for example we're making use of the
y finance library
so we're gonna copy this line we also
made use of the matplotlib library
and so we're gonna find matplotlib right
here and then we're gonna copy that
and then do the same thing for all of
the other libraries that you're using
okay so essentially you have the app
file itself
you have the requirements.txt and then
you also have the readme.md file
so this is normally created
automatically if you ticked on it
and it will allow you to show this
readme
here so i'm going to show you how you
could include a button
that will allow you to click on it and
then it will
launch the web application okay so let
me open up the
share streamlet website
share streamlet and so it should be
noted that
for this one i've signed in using my
github
so let me try signing out and so for the
first time when you sign
in it will ask for your authorization
that you're allowing streamlet to have
access to your github account and so i
have already done that so it's going to
log in seamlessly
okay and so this is the dashboard part
of
the share streamlet website upon logging
in
and so i'm going to deploy the first web
application here
so i'm going to click on the new app
button
all right and then i'm going to click on
the repository
and then i'm going to click on the data
professor streamlet10
and then the branch will automatically
detect to be main
because if i go back to the github here
notice that
this says mean okay
or it could be master depending on your
own github profile
all right and then let's have a look at
what is the name of the app
and it's called sp500 dash app dot py
let's copy that
paste it here and then that's all we
need to do in order to deploy the app
and then you
click on the deploy button
and then wait for a while
and so if you see this icon coming up it
means that
your app is probably going to be
successfully deployed
given that you also have the
requirements.text
file that i have mentioned previously
so in just a moment while it is
installing all of the necessary
libraries for you
all right so you see all of the log here
so most of it has met the requirement
here
and it has already installed the y
finance library
and it says here that it has processed
the dependency
and then you saw the balloons it means
that it had already successfully
deployed
so let me click on this bottom right
button in order to minimize it
or i could bring it up again by clicking
the manage app
and then hide it again
alright and so congratulations now you
have
successfully deployed the web
application
onto the streamlit website in the
share.streamlit.io
so let's have a look at the plots here
we see one plot here if i move to two
then i'll be seeing two plots here
all right so there you have it this is
the deployed web application
which is quite easy and it should be
noted that
currently right now streamlit is hosting
a
beta trial so it means that you need to
be
in the 1000 selected users in order to
try out this new feature
so head over to the streamlet share
website and click on
request for invitation so that the
streamlet team will
invite you to try out this awesome
feature
and so i'll provide you the links to
that as well